Hello and welcome to your second drink of The Convict. You guys put on your purple bandanas because it's time for Prison Mike. Oh Prison Mike, who might be one of Michael Scott's most legendary alter ego characters. I mean if we're going off of Halloween costumes, I would say that's one I see a lot. A lot for sure. Well, we got a letter from Warwick S. in Springville, Utah. It was the most wonderful letter. Thank you so much. And it included an amazing deep dive based on one of your shares from when we broke down the convict, Angela. So I'm sure you remember that you explained that there was a
你好，欢迎收听《办公室女郎》的第二杯“囚犯”特辑。大家快戴上你们的紫色头巾，因为“监狱迈克”时间到了。哦，监狱迈克，他可能是迈克尔·斯科特最传奇的化身角色之一。我是说，如果我们要参考万圣节服装的话，我觉得这是我见过很多次的一个。绝对很多。好吧，我们收到了一封来自犹他州斯普林维尔的沃里克·S的来信。这是一封非常棒的信。非常感谢。它还包含了一个基于你们分享的深度解析，当时我们拆解了《囚犯》那一集，安吉拉。所以我相信你还记得你解释过有一个
deleted talking head where Michael talks about the time a person dressed as an owl came to his school. Yeah. And this is going to explain sort of the origin of Prison Mike. Well, they added this to the Peacock superfan episode of The Convict. In our breakdown, you read it, but I thought maybe we should hear it.
被删减的谈话片段，迈克尔在里面谈到了他学校里有个打扮成猫头鹰的人来访的事。是的。这解释了“监狱迈克”的起源。好吧，他们把这段加到了孔雀台《囚犯》的超级粉丝版里。在我们的拆解中，你读过它，但我认为也许我们应该听听看。
OK. When I was just a little kid, We had an assembly at school where a giant owl came out and gave a very impassioned speech about giving hoots and not polluting. And you know what? I never polluted again. It was right then that I realized the power of saying things as a character. People listen to you when you are wearing an elaborate costume or speaking in a voice that is not yours. It was an amazing find, Angela, and I love that they've added it back to the Peacock episode.
好的。当我还是个小孩子的时候，学校里举行了一次集会，一只巨大的猫头鹰走出来，发表了一番关于“发出呼声，不要污染”的慷慨激昂的演讲。你知道吗？我再也没有污染过环境。就在那时，我意识到以角色身份说话的力量。当你穿着精致的服装或用不是你自己的声音说话时，人们会听你的。这是一个了不起的发现，安吉拉，我很高兴他们把它加回了孔雀台的版本里。
It explains so much. I know. Well, Warwick wanted us to know that this owl character is real. Warwick was on a hike and saw a sign that said, quote, "'Give a hoot, don't pollute,' with the photo of an owl, and wrote us to say, quote, "'So although I'm not a lady,
这解释了很多事情。我知道。好吧，沃里克想让我们知道这个猫头鹰角色是真实存在的。沃里克在徒步旅行时看到一个牌子，上面写着，引用：“发出呼声，不要污染”，并配有一张猫头鹰的照片，他写信告诉我们，引用：“虽然我不是一位女士，
I became a lady who Googles and looked it up. And ladies, it did not disappoint. It led me to discover that Woodsy Owl was a character created alongside Smokey Bear in efforts to combat pollution and deforestization. But according to the internet, Woodsy Owl was discontinued due to the polarizing spotted owl
但我成了一位会谷歌搜索的女士，并查了一下。女士们，它没有让人失望。它让我发现“伍兹猫头鹰”是一个与“斯莫基熊”一起创造的角色，旨在打击污染和森林砍伐。但根据互联网的说法，伍兹猫头鹰因为20世纪80年代极具争议的斑点猫头鹰
controversy of the 1980s. What controversy? Much like the band Mallard of Louisiana, Woodsy was a very unpopular bird and the government requested that all Woodsy Owl costumes be incinerated. Wow. Ladies, I have only scratched the surface on Woodsy Owl. There are so many unanswered questions, but I thought I'd let the mom detective solve this one. I also love that Warwick brought back my band mallard.
争议而被停用了。什么争议？就像路易斯安那州的野鸭乐队一样，伍兹是一只非常不受欢迎的鸟，政府要求销毁所有伍兹猫头鹰的服装。哇。女士们，我只是触及了伍兹猫头鹰的皮毛。还有很多未解之谜，但我认为还是让妈妈侦探来解决这个吧。我也很喜欢沃里克提到了我的野鸭乐队。
I know. So thank you for getting us started. We did look this up. And you're right. The Woodsy Owl was introduced in September, 1971 to help combat pollution. Initially, there was a discussion of making Woodsy a trout, an elk, or a raccoon.
我知道。所以谢谢你让我们开始。我们确实查过了。你是对的。伍兹猫头鹰是在1971年9月推出的，旨在帮助打击污染。最初，有人讨论过把伍兹做成鳟鱼、麋鹿或浣熊。
But instead, they decided to go with an owl due to the wise nature of the bird and how they could be found at the edges of urban areas, which they believed would make the owl appealing to urban and rural populations. They really put a lot of thought into this. Woodsy is also much shorter than Smokey the Bear, and that was intentional. Woodsy was designed to be the same height as kids to better appeal to them. He even had his own theme song. You gotta hear it. Hi, I'm Woodsy Owl. In order to try and stop pollution, we need more help. So help Woodsy spread the word.
但最终，他们决定选择猫头鹰，因为这种鸟的智慧天性，以及它们可以在城市边缘被发现，他们认为这会让猫头鹰对城市和农村人口都有吸引力。他们确实在这上面花了很多心思。伍兹也比斯莫基熊矮得多，这是故意的。伍兹的设计高度与孩子们相同，以更好地吸引他们。他甚至有自己的主题曲。你一定要听听。嗨，我是伍兹猫头鹰。为了尝试停止污染，我们需要更多帮助。所以帮助伍兹传播这个信息。
Come on, never be a dirty bird. No matter where you go, you can let some people know to give a hoot, don't pollute. Never be a dirty bird. In the city or in the woods. Help keep America looking good. Don't be a dirty bird. I have questions. Dirty bird is like innuendo.
来吧，永远不要做一只脏鸟。无论你去哪里，你都可以告诉人们要发出呼声，不要污染。永远不要做一只脏鸟。在城市里或在树林里。帮助保持美国的美丽。不要做一只脏鸟。我有疑问。脏鸟是不是一种暗示？
Like if you're a dirty bird. Why? What do you mean? What? Right? Sam? Right? Sam? Yes, yes. What is a dirty bird? What?
就像如果你是一只脏鸟。为什么？你是什么意思？什么？对吧？萨姆？对吧？萨姆？是的，是的。什么是脏鸟？什么？
What do you think a dirty bird is? Don't be a dirty bird. It's like a penis. It's like don't be a... A hussy. Don't be a peeper. Oh, I thought you were saying like... Don't be a dirty bird.
你认为脏鸟是什么？不要做一只脏鸟。这就像阴茎。这就像不要做……一个荡妇。不要做一个偷窥狂。哦，我以为你在说……不要做一只脏鸟。
Like... I mean... Like a peeping tom is a dirty bird. like, like a dirty bird. I thought I, I mean. Like a peeping Tom is a dirty bird. Oh, okay. Don't be a dirty bird. I thought it was like, don't have a dirty piece or something. No. How did you make that leap? No. Like a bird. I didn't know if a bird was like a, you know.
就像……我是说……就像偷窥狂是一只脏鸟。就像，就像一只脏鸟。我以为我，我是说。就像偷窥狂是一只脏鸟。哦，好吧。不要做一只脏鸟。我以为它是说，不要有脏东西之类的。不。你是怎么得出这个结论的？不。就像一只鸟。我不知道鸟是不是像，你知道的。
No, it's like a like a pervert. Like, don't be a dirty bird. Like if it's a nice way of calling someone a pervert, right? A dirty bird. I imagined it as like a like a hussy or a slut. You're like a dirty bird. Oh, so this, okay, this is interesting. So to you, it's shaming women.
不，它就像一个变态。就像，不要做一只脏鸟。就像这是一种称呼某人为变态的好听方式，对吧？一只脏鸟。我把它想象成一个荡妇或妓女。你就像一只脏鸟。哦，所以这个，好吧，这很有趣。所以对你来说，这是在羞辱女性。
Yes. To me, it's shaming men. Yeah. To me, it's like a not well-kept penis. It's just literally a penis. An unkempt penis. A dirty penis. Well, anyway, my point here is that I am surprised that we use Dirty Bird twice in the Woodsy the Owl song. But anyway, I'm guessing that Woodsy the Owl is who came to Michael's school.
是的。对我来说，这是在羞辱男性。是的。对我来说，这就像一个没洗干净的阴茎。它字面上就是一个阴茎。一个没打理过的阴茎。一个脏阴茎。好吧，无论如何，我的观点是，我很惊讶我们在伍兹猫头鹰的歌里用了两次“脏鸟”。但无论如何，我猜伍兹猫头鹰就是那个来到迈克尔学校的角色。
And I saw online that it is true that they discontinued Woodsy, but they reintroduced him again in the 1990s, I think. The National Forest Service celebrated his 50th birthday recently. There you have it, Warwick. Thank you. Yeah. Also, lady, during our breakdown of this episode, we got a fan mail flurry about a mystery item on the desk in the annex. We discuss it in the annex.
我在网上看到，他们确实停用了伍兹，但我想他们在90年代又重新引入了他。国家森林局最近庆祝了他的50岁生日。就是这样，沃里克。谢谢你。是的。还有，女士，在我们拆解这一集时，我们收到了大量关于附件办公桌上一个神秘物品的粉丝来信。我们在附件里讨论过它。
We discuss it in the breakdown. We say it looked like a mini fireplace or something. And I believe we may have solved this mystery as well. Yes, we got a letter from Chris C that might have solved it. Chris said, I was able to figure out what the mystery item was that looked like a heater. You first see it at six minutes, 27 seconds,
我们在拆解中讨论过它。我们说它看起来像个迷你壁炉之类的。我相信我们也可能解决了这个谜团。是的，我们收到了一封来自克里斯·C的信，可能解决了这个问题。克里斯说，我能够弄清楚那个看起来像加热器的神秘物品是什么。你第一次在6分27秒看到它，
and we are seeing two things. The part that we see moving is a desktop water fountain, very similar to the HomeMedics MiraZen Tabletop relaxation fountain. You can see the fountain in action on several YouTube videos. Search for HomeMedics MiraZen Tabletop relaxation fountain on QVC. Say that 10 times fast.
我们看到了两样东西。我们看到移动的部分是一个桌面喷泉，非常类似于HomeMedics MiraZen桌面放松喷泉。你可以在几个YouTube视频中看到这个喷泉的运作。在QVC上搜索HomeMedics MiraZen桌面放松喷泉。快速说十遍。
Directly behind it, we have a stack of file folders sitting in a black metal upright folder organizer. You can see an identical sorter with white paper and a red folder on the end of Martin's desk at six minutes, 18 seconds. This makes it look like a large cylinder, but it's actually two separate items. Wow.
在它正后方，我们有一叠放在黑色金属立式文件夹整理器里的文件夹。你可以在6分18秒马丁办公桌的末端看到一个一模一样的分类器，里面有白纸和一个红色的文件夹。这让它看起来像一个大圆柱体，但实际上是两个独立的物品。哇。
Wow, there you go. So we're really solving some mysteries in our second drink today. All right, well, listen, before we get to our breakdown of the merger, we've got some office ladies news. You guys, this is a big deal for us. I think you all know I do our Wednesdays Instagram. And I mean, you know, it kind of looks like it's just me doing it. It's not too fancy.
哇，就是这样。所以我们今天在第二杯节目里真的解决了一些谜团。好吧，听着，在我们开始拆解合并那一集之前，我们有一些办公室女郎的新闻。伙计们，这对我们来说是一件大事。我想你们都知道我负责我们的周三Instagram。我是说，你知道，看起来好像只是我在做。它不太花哨。
You do a good job, lady. And I don't want to hear you poo poo it in any way. Okay. It's very good. That's very sweet of you. But we've been talking for a long time that, you know, maybe we also want to have an office ladies TikTok or YouTube shorts, but that's just too much
你做得很好，女士。我不想听到你以任何方式贬低它。好的。这太贴心了。但我们已经讨论了很长时间，你知道，也许我们也想拥有一个办公室女郎的TikTok或YouTube短片，但这对我来说太难了
for me to figure out. I don't know how to do all that. So we got some help with this great group of young folks that are so creative, Block Party. They're gonna be helping us with all that. Yes, we are so excited. You can now find us on Instagram, TikTok, and YouTube at Office Ladies Pod.
去弄清楚。我不知道怎么做所有这些。所以我们从这群非常有创造力的年轻人那里得到了一些帮助，Block Party。他们会帮我们处理所有这些。是的，我们太兴奋了。你现在可以在Instagram、TikTok和YouTube上找到我们，账号是Office Ladies Pod。
And they're gonna help us make reels and fun stuff. I don't know, this feels very exciting to us. So check us out if you're on the other platforms. We'd love to see you over there. Yeah, we'll share in our stories. Well, listen, that's all we've got. So now please enjoy The Convict. I'm Jenna Fisher.
他们会帮我们制作短片和有趣的东西。我不知道，这让我们感到非常兴奋。所以如果你在其他平台上，来看看我们。我们很乐意在那里见到你。是的，我们会在我们的故事里分享。好吧，听着，这就是我们所有的内容了。所以现在请享受《囚犯》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hey everybody. Hi you guys. This week we are talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes.
我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极办公室重温播客。每周我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。嘿，大家好。嗨，伙计们。这周我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。
And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes.
我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。
And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. And we're going to be talking about the convict scenes. Hey everybody! Hi you guys! This week we are talking about The Convict, Season 3, Episode 9, written by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant and directed by Jeffrey Blitz.
我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。我们要谈论的是《囚犯》的场景。嘿，大家好！嗨，伙计们！这周我们要谈论的是《囚犯》，第三季第九集，由瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特编剧，杰弗里·布里茨导演。
There's some powerhouse there. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Well, I'm wasting no time. I'm gonna hit you with a summary. Hit me baby one more time. Oh yeah. I'm wasting no time. I'm going to hit you with a summary. Hit me baby one more time. Oh baby, baby.
那里有一些大人物。哦，是的。哦，是的。哦，是的。哦，是的。好吧，我不想浪费时间。我要给你一个总结。再给我一次总结吧，宝贝。哦，是的。我不想浪费时间。我要给你一个总结。再给我一次总结吧，宝贝。哦，宝贝，宝贝。
Just give me a summary. Oh my God. Oh, Brittany, we love you. All right. In this episode, Michael learns that one of the new Stamford transfers, Martin Nash is a reformed convict. When Martin tells the other employees about his time in prison, the staff says it sounds like it's better than working at Dunder Mifflin. Well, Michael is heartbroken to hear
给我一个总结就行了。哦，天哪。哦，布兰妮，我们爱你。好的。在这一集中，迈克尔得知斯坦福的新调任员工之一马丁·纳什是一名改过自新的囚犯。当马丁告诉其他员工他在监狱里的时光时，员工们说听起来比在邓德·米夫林工作还要好。好吧，迈克尔听到这些很伤心，
that people would rather be in prison than at Dunder Mifflin. So he responds by turning into Prison Mike to scare them all straight. And then also, Andy asks Jim for advice on how to whoop him and we get a little bit of a prank. He's going to whoop him. There's going to be some banjo playing. It's a real special.
人们宁愿在监狱里也不愿在邓德·米夫林。所以他通过变身“监狱迈克”来吓唬他们，让他们走上正轨。然后，安迪向吉姆寻求关于如何教训他的建议，我们还看到了一点恶作剧。他要教训他。会有一些班卓琴演奏。这真的很特别。
Jenna, I know you're about to hit me with some fast facts, but I bet I can guess two of them. Hit you with some fast facts. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no, this is fast. People right now are hitting fast forward. They're like, please can I skip past them doing Britney Spears?
珍娜，我知道你正要给我一些快速事实，但我敢打赌我能猜中其中两个。给你一些快速事实。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不，这很快。人们现在正在快进。他们就像，求求你们，我能跳过他们模仿布兰妮·斯皮尔斯吗？
Is your first fast fact that Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant created the office for the BBC? They're the OG of the OG? Yes, Angela. It is. Yes, and. It is. Yes. And also, this is the only episode of The American Office that was written by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant. I didn't know that. Well, our pilot was sort of technically written by them
你的第一个快速事实是瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特为BBC创作了《办公室》吗？他们是鼻祖中的鼻祖？是的，安吉拉。确实是。是的，而且。确实是。是的。而且，这是美国版《办公室》中唯一一集由瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特编剧的。我不知道这一点。好吧，我们的试播集在技术上算是他们写的，
because we really we used so much of it, but it was also adapted by Greg Daniels. But this is the only original American office that they wrote. Now, Stephen did direct an episode. He directed Customer Survey in season five. And Ricky did a cameo in season seven. And they were around. They would come visit us.
因为我们确实用了它很多内容，但它也是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯改编的。但这是他们写的唯一一集原创美国版《办公室》。现在，斯蒂芬确实导演了一集。他导演了第五季的《客户调查》。瑞奇在第七季客串过。他们就在附近。他们会来看我们。
They would pop in. I remember Stephen Merchant being in the writer's room a lot. He would come by whenever he was in America. And you know, Angela, I in. I remember Stephen Merchant being in the writer's room a lot. Yeah. He would come by whenever he was in America. And you know, Angela, I did a movie with Stephen Merchant. You did a movie with the tall man from England? Yes. It was called Hall Pass.
他们会顺道拜访。我记得斯蒂芬·莫昌特经常在编剧室。他每次在美国时都会过来。你知道，安吉拉，我……我记得斯蒂芬·莫昌特经常在编剧室。是的。他每次在美国时都会过来。你知道，安吉拉，我和斯蒂芬·莫昌特拍过一部电影。你和那个来自英国的高个子男人拍过电影？是的。它叫《放通行证》。
Oh. And it was a Fairleigh Brothers movie. It shot in Atlanta. And I was so happy that Stephen Merchant was on this movie because this movie had like these huge powerhouse comedic stars. Okay, it was Owen Wilson, there was Jason Sudeikis, JB Smoove, Christina Applegate, and then like me. I remember. I remember you going off to do this and you were like,
哦。那是法雷利兄弟的电影。在亚特兰大拍摄的。我很高兴斯蒂芬·莫昌特参演了这部电影，因为这部电影里有这些巨大的喜剧明星。好吧，有欧文·威尔逊，有杰森·苏戴奇斯，JB·斯穆夫，克里斯蒂娜·艾伯盖特，还有我。我记得。我记得你去拍这部电影时，你说，
oh my God, I'm so nervous. I'm so nervous. I was so happy that I knew someone. Yeah. So I kind of glommed on to Stephen Merchant when we were on that set because I was like someone I know. Because otherwise when you go to those movies, I always feel like the new kid in school where it's like, where do I fit in? I don't know anyone.
哦，天哪，我好紧张。我好紧张。我很高兴我认识某个人。是的。所以我有点粘着斯蒂芬·莫昌特，因为我们在那个片场时，我觉得我认识某个人。因为否则当你去拍那些电影时，我总是觉得自己像学校里的新生，就像，我该融入哪里？我不认识任何人。
Yeah. I was so nervous. But there was another reason why I was very nervous on this movie. And it was because I was staying in a haunted hotel. What? Yes, you remember this? No! Lady!
是的。我太紧张了。但还有另一个原因让我在这部电影里非常紧张。那是因为我住在一个闹鬼的酒店。什么？是的，你还记得这个吗？不！女士！
Yes, I got to Atlanta and they put me up in this hotel. I would get woken up in the middle of the night at like 2 30 in the morning by the sound of clompy footsteps on my ceiling. Well, that happens in hotels, lady. Does it happen when your hotel room is on the top floor and there's nothing above you? clumpy footsteps on my ceiling. Well, that happens in hotels, lady. Does it happen when your hotel room is on the top floor and there's nothing above you? Does it? No, I was on the top floor. So I called down to the front desk and I was like, excuse me, do you guys do maintenance on the roof at like two thirty in the morning? Are people walking on the roof?
是的，我到了亚特兰大，他们把我安排在这个酒店。我会在半夜两点半左右被天花板上沉重的脚步声吵醒。好吧，酒店里常有这种事，女士。当你的酒店房间在顶楼，上面什么都没有时，也会发生吗？沉重的脚步声在我的天花板上。好吧，酒店里常有这种事，女士。当你的酒店房间在顶楼，上面什么都没有时，也会发生吗？会吗？不，我在顶楼。所以我打电话给前台，我说，打扰一下，你们会在凌晨两点半在屋顶做维护吗？有人在屋顶上走吗？
And well, the person on the phone was like 2.30 in the morning? Are people walking on the roof? What? Well, the person on the phone was like, no. And also, just because you're on the top floor, they're like, that doesn't mean that like your ceiling is literally the roof of the building. Like there's stuff in between. What stuff? Like the ceiling of your hotel. Like a secret floor?
好吧，电话那头的人说，凌晨两点半？有人在屋顶上走吗？什么？好吧，电话那头的人说，没有。而且，仅仅因为你在顶楼，他们说，那并不意味着你的天花板就是建筑的屋顶。中间还有东西。什么东西？就像你酒店的天花板。就像一个秘密楼层？
That's what I said. Yes. I said, what's happening there? Like when you get in an elevator and there's no button for it? Yes, that's what I wanted to know said, what's happening there? Like when you get in an elevator and there's no button for it? Yes! That's what I wanted to know. What is happening in this space?
我就是这么说的。是的。我说，那里发生了什么？就像当你走进电梯，却没有按钮时？是的，这就是我想知道的，我说，那里发生了什么？就像当你走进电梯，却没有按钮时？是的！这就是我想知道的。那个空间里发生了什么？
Something is happening. People are walking. They insisted that I was not hearing these noises. They insisted. Angela, I wouldn't let it go. Well, of course not. So I went to a travel website and I Googled this hotel. You did a deep dive on the hotel.
发生了什么事。有人在走动。他们坚持说我没有听到这些声音。他们坚持。安吉拉，我不会放过它的。好吧，当然不会。所以我去了一个旅游网站，谷歌搜索了这个酒店。你对这个酒店做了深度解析。
It's a haunted hotel. Oh no. There were tons of stories of people who had stayed on the top floor, who had heard the footsteps. Shut the front door. Okay, so now I can't sleep, right? Cause you have a full on ghost.
这是一个闹鬼的酒店。哦，不。有无数故事说住在顶楼的人听到了脚步声。关上那扇门。好吧，现在我睡不着了，对吧？因为你有一个完整的鬼魂。
I'm in a ghost hotel. I have to go to work tomorrow with Owen Wilson. I'm sleepless. I'm nervous. I called Lee crying in the middle of the night. Lee, who was my boyfriend at the time, who's back in Los Angeles writing a script, I was like, you need to fly here, and you have to come keep me safe from the ghosts.
我在一个鬼酒店。我明天要和欧文·威尔逊一起工作。我失眠了。我很紧张。我半夜哭着给李打电话。李，我当时的男朋友，他当时在洛杉矶写剧本，我说，你需要飞到这里来，你必须来保护我免受鬼魂的伤害。
You have to stay with me during this movie. And he's like, what am I, a ghost buster? What the heck, Jenna, just move hotels. That's what Lee said. But I was like, what am I, a ghost buster? What the heck Jenna, just move hotels. That's what Lee said. But I was like, I am not about to call this production company and insist that they move me from this hotel because it's haunted. They would think you were Looney Tunes.
你必须在这部电影拍摄期间和我待在一起。他说，我是什么，捉鬼敢死队吗？搞什么鬼，珍娜，换个酒店就行了。李就是这么说的。但我说，我是什么，捉鬼敢死队吗？搞什么鬼，珍娜，换个酒店就行了。李就是这么说的。但我说，我才不会打电话给制作公司，坚持要他们给我换酒店，因为这里闹鬼。他们会以为你疯了。
They would be like, oh, this actress is convinced her hotel room is haunted and she wants to move. I get it. I get it. So Lee flew out, he stayed with me while I shot that movie and protected me from the ghost. And by the way, when he got there, he heard it. He heard it.
他们会说，哦，这个女演员确信她的酒店房间闹鬼，她想换房间。我懂了。我懂了。所以李飞了过来，他在我拍那部电影时一直陪着我，保护我免受鬼魂的伤害。顺便说一句，当他到那里时，他也听到了。他听到了。
I would be so freaked out. Oh my gosh, that fast fact took a turn, but I like it. It really did. I'm here for it. I'm gonna steer us back onto the episode with fast fact number two. This was the first episode directed by Jeff Blitz. We love Jeff Blitz.
我会吓坏的。哦，天哪，那个快速事实发生了转折，但我喜欢它。我支持它。我要把我们带回这一集，快速事实二。这是杰夫·布里茨导演的第一集。我们爱杰夫·布里茨。
He directed 11 episodes of The Office. This was his first. He is a wonderful, delightful human being. I adore him. We reached out to Jeff and he sent in audio clips about this episode. We're so excited. I also told him I really need him to come back on because we need to discuss Save Bandit. And when I threw that cat in the ceiling, that has to be talked about.
他导演了11集《办公室》。这是他的第一集。他是一个美妙、令人愉快的人。我崇拜他。我们联系了杰夫，他发来了关于这一集的音频片段。我们太兴奋了。我还告诉他，我真的需要他回来，因为我们需要讨论“拯救班迪特”。还有当我把那只猫扔进天花板时，那必须得谈谈。
Because he directed that episode too, right? Yes. But you guys, I want to give a shout out to a movie that Jeff had done. I had watched this movie. It's a documentary. I was a huge fan of it and a fan of his. So I kind of geeked out when he finally got to direct an episode, but he directed a documentary called Spellbound. It is a fantastic documentary about the Scripps National Spelling Bee
因为他也导演了那一集，对吧？是的。但是伙计们，我想向杰夫做过的一部电影致敬。我看过这部电影。这是一部纪录片。我是它的忠实粉丝，也是他的粉丝。所以当他终于能导演一集时，我有点疯狂，但他导演了一部名为《拼字比赛》的纪录片。这是一部关于斯克里普斯全国拼字比赛的精彩纪录片，
and it follows eight of the young competitors. It is wonderful. So if you're looking for things to watch, watch Spellbound. It is so good. It was nominated for an Academy Award. Yes. Oh my God, I forgot that. Yes, it's so good. Well, we asked Jeff, how'd you get this job?
它跟踪了八名年轻选手。它太棒了。所以如果你在找东西看，看《拼字比赛》。它太好了。它获得了奥斯卡提名。是的。哦，天哪，我忘了那个。是的，它太好了。好吧，我们问杰夫，你是怎么得到这份工作的？
And I loved his answer. So, Sam, will you play that clip? When Greg was meeting people to talk about directing on the pilot, I got called in to meet with him. He was flirting with the great and probably crazy idea to bring a true doc filmmaker on from the start to kind of overlay a more authentic doc style onto the show.
我很喜欢他的回答。所以，萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？当格雷格在见人谈论试播集的导演工作时，我被叫去见他。他当时在考虑一个伟大但可能疯狂的想法，即从一开始就引入一位真正的纪录片制作人，为节目叠加一种更真实的纪录片风格。
I had just done my first feature doc, Spellbound, about kids in the national spelling bee, and Greg thought the idea to have me on was an interesting one that he'd explore with NBC, who immediately said, not a chance. I think it was almost two years later, I hadn't seen Greg at all, with NBC who immediately said, not a chance. I think it was almost two years later, I hadn't seen Greg at all, and I got a call out of the blue.
我刚完成了我的第一部纪录片长片《拼字比赛》，关于全国拼字比赛的孩子们，格雷格认为让我加入的想法很有趣，他会和NBC探讨，NBC立即说，没门。我想那是近两年后，我根本没见过格雷格，和NBC探讨，NBC立即说，没门。我想那是近两年后，我根本没见过格雷格，我突然接到了一个电话。
Greg wanted to know now what I like to work on the show. At this point, he thought that he could talk NBC into it. So, the Office Season 3, I had my first gig in the world of TV with the episode, The Convict. Yeah, so this was his first scripted television show that he ever directed. He was just coming out of the world of documentary, which I love. I love that Greg did that, right? That he wanted a cinematographer who had shot documentaries and now he wanted to hire a documentary film director. He was really interested in preserving the integrity of this documentary style for the show.
格雷格现在想知道我是否愿意参与这个节目。此时，他认为他可以说服NBC。所以，《办公室》第三季，我有了我的第一份电视工作，就是《囚犯》这一集。是的，所以这是他导演的第一部剧本电视节目。他刚从纪录片世界出来，我喜欢这一点。我喜欢格雷格那样做，对吧？他想要一位拍过纪录片的摄影师，现在他想聘请一位纪录片导演。他真的很有兴趣为节目保持这种纪录片风格的完整性。
I also love that Greg is such a champion of people. You know, he doesn't give up on you. NBC said no. He was like, I'm going to get you in there, Jeff. You know? And then he did. I just love that. We also asked Jeff what it was like to shoot his first scripted television show. And here's what he had to say.
我也喜欢格雷格是这样的人才拥护者。你知道，他不会放弃你。NBC说不。他说，我会让你进去的，杰夫。你知道吗？然后他做到了。我就是喜欢这一点。我们还问杰夫导演他的第一部剧本电视节目是什么感觉。他是这样说的。
The thing that stood out to me is that I had done all this prep work, figuring out all these shots. And, you know, I just had a ton of thoughts about the way each line might be. And then when the shooting actually started, I realized that all the prep work I had done just didn't fit for the kind of show that this was. The first or second setup, I think, had me standing right by Pam's desk. And I realized that by then, all of the prep work I had done, it just didn't make any sense.
让我印象深刻的是，我做了所有的准备工作，弄清楚了所有这些镜头。而且，你知道，我对每一句台词可能的样子有很多想法。然后当拍摄真正开始时，我意识到我所做的所有准备工作根本不适合这种节目。我想第一或第二个设置让我站在帕姆的办公桌旁。我意识到到那时，我所做的所有准备工作，根本没有任何意义。
And I think that I just dropped all of it into the trash can right there. Well, Angela, I remember Jeff standing at reception for that scene. Yeah. And we really bonded. I felt so fortunate that I got to have him up at reception with me because I just loved him instantly.
我想我就把它们全部扔进垃圾桶了。好吧，安吉拉，我记得杰夫站在前台拍那个场景。是的。我们真的建立了联系。我觉得我很幸运能让他和我在前台，因为我立刻就爱上了他。
I feel like reception, you got that sometimes. Like, just sitting where you were sitting, a lot of times that directors and writers would be sort of perched up there, either on that sofa, you know, they would sit on the sofa right there and watch the scene. And I was a little jealous that you got to have all that time with them. Well, the other thing that used to happen at reception, though, Angela, is that people would stand like a wall in front of reception with their back to me, and they would also
我觉得前台，你有时会那样。就像，坐在你坐的地方，很多时候导演和编剧会栖息在那里，要么在那张沙发上，你知道，他们会坐在那里的沙发上观看场景。我有点嫉妒你和他们有那么多时间。好吧，安吉拉，前台过去常发生另一件事，就是人们会像一堵墙一样站在前台前面，背对着我，他们还会
steal my pens and they would also leave their water bottles on the reception desk. So there's an upside and a downside. There was. There was. All right, are you ready for fast fact number three? I am. Fast fact number three, Wayne Wilderson, amazing comic actor, played Martin Nash. We also reached out to Wayne and he sent in some audio clips about his time on the show. He did, Jenna. This time I was sliding into someone's DMs. Oh, I loved it. I loved it.
偷我的笔，他们还会把水瓶留在前台。所以有优点也有缺点。确实有。确实有。好吧，你准备好迎接快速事实三了吗？我准备好了。快速事实三，韦恩·威尔德森，了不起的喜剧演员，饰演马丁·纳什。我们也联系了韦恩，他发来了一些关于他在节目中时光的音频片段。他发了，珍娜。这次我滑进了某人的私信。哦，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。
I love that now you and I are just these two ladies in their 40s sliding into people's DMs. I know, right? Wayne is fantastic. And we started by asking him how he came to be on the office and here's what he had to say. Hey guys, it's Wayne here. How you doing?
我喜欢现在你和我只是这两个四十多岁的女士滑进人们的私信。我知道，对吧？韦恩太棒了。我们首先问他是如何来到《办公室》的，他是这样说的。嘿，伙计们，我是韦恩。你们好吗？
Thank you so much for letting me come to the party. This is great. I dig the podcast. Okay, jumping right into it. Question one, can you share how you came to be on The Office? Yeah, I got to be on The Office. Yeah, I got to be on The Office. It was just a regular audition call. They had this role. It was two episodes, working two different weeks. And I already loved the show. And I was a big fan of the British office. So I was very excited for this audition.
非常感谢你们让我来参加派对。这太棒了。我喜欢这个播客。好的，直接进入正题。问题一，你能分享一下你是怎么来到《办公室》的吗？是的，我能来到《办公室》。是的，我能来到《办公室》。这只是一个普通的试镜电话。他们有这个角色。是两集，在两周内工作。我本来就喜欢这个节目。我是英国版《办公室》的忠实粉丝。所以我对这次试镜非常兴奋。
I knew Steve and I knew Ed, I just worked with those guys and Evan Almighty. Nancy, Steve's wife, is one of my oldest friends, but they swore they had nothing to do with getting me audition. So that's what they said. But I got the job and was super excited. In that particular episode, But I got the job and was super excited. And that particular episode, I'm not sure if I knew when I got the part that Ricky Gervais
我认识史蒂夫，也认识艾德，我刚和那些家伙在《冒牌天神2》里合作过。南希，史蒂夫的妻子，是我最老的朋友之一，但他们发誓他们和我得到试镜机会没有任何关系。所以他们是这么说的。但我得到了这份工作，非常兴奋。在那一集中，但我得到了这份工作，非常兴奋。在那一集中，我不确定我得到角色时是否知道瑞奇·热维斯
and Stephen Merchant had written it. And I think it was the two episodes were the first ones that they ever did for the US office. So that was a bit of an oh-on, huh? I did not know that he knew Nancy. I didn't either, but it makes sense. Right? I mean, they're both really funny, talented people. They were in Boston. I don't know. I know. I see them crossing paths.
和斯蒂芬·莫昌特写了它。我想这两集是他们为美国版《办公室》做的最初的两集。所以那有点让人惊讶，对吧？我不知道他认识南希。我也不知道，但这说得通。对吧？我是说，他们都是非常有趣、有才华的人。他们在波士顿。我不知道。我知道。我看到他们交集。
No, they have the comedy connection and the Boston connection. So I guess that makes sense. Well, you know, when we were trading emails with Wayne too, we asked him if he still gets recognized for being on The Office, and he said yes all the time, especially now with the resurgence on Netflix. And he's so tickled by it, but he said it's all young people now. Oh yeah, I mean, we're crushing it
不，他们有喜剧联系和波士顿联系。所以我猜这说得通。好吧，你知道，当我们和韦恩交换邮件时，我们也问他是否仍然因为出演《办公室》而被认出来，他说一直都是，特别是在Netflix重新上线之后。他对此感到非常高兴，但他说是全是年轻人。哦，是的，我是说，我们正在征服
with middle schoolers, guys. Because we talked about this on The Merger, he had a big recurring on Veep as well, but I think he gets recognized more for The Office even though it was only two episodes. Oh, Veep is so good. So good. You know, we exchanged a lot of emails with Wayne about this episode and we were talking about what it was like to rewatch this episode in light of everything that's happening in
初中生，伙计们。因为我们在《合并》那一集中谈过，他在《副总统》中也有重要的常驻角色，但我认为他因为《办公室》被认出来的次数更多，尽管只有两集。哦，《副总统》太好了。太好了。你知道，我们和韦恩就这一集交换了很多邮件，我们谈论了在考虑到目前发生的一切的情况下重温这一集是什么感觉
our country with the Black Lives Matter movement. And here's what he had to say. Wow, I just watched it again. I watched it, you know, maybe every year or so. It's such a good episode with everything that's going on in the world now. You know, it feels a little even edgier at some points, but it's super poignant, I guess,
我们的国家有“黑人的命也是命”运动。他是这样说的。哇，我刚又看了一遍。我看了，你知道，可能每年左右。这是一集非常好的节目，考虑到世界上现在发生的一切。你知道，在某些方面感觉更尖锐，但我想它超级深刻，
for all of the issues that we're dealing with now with race and how we deal with it and what's funny and what's not funny and who can say what when. This puts a magnifying glass on where we've been and how far we've come along, where we've been and how far we've come along, what comedy we can do. So it was very interesting. I probably hadn't watched it in a year or so. And to watch it during these times was very interesting. With that, the comedy and its commentary, I think it holds up very well.
对于我们现在处理的所有关于种族的问题，以及我们如何处理它，什么是好笑的，什么是不好笑的，谁可以在什么时候说什么。这把放大镜放在了我们走过的地方以及我们走了多远，我们走过的地方以及我们走了多远，我们可以做什么喜剧。所以这非常有趣。我可能有一年左右没看了。在这些时候看它非常有趣。有了这些，喜剧及其评论，我认为它经受住了考验。
I think it's kind of a classic Office episode. I'm gonna say it's a classic Office episode. Boom. Well, Angela, I had not watched this episode since it aired, and I definitely found a new poignancy when I was watching it. Oh, yeah. And there are definitely lines and moments that stood out to me.
我认为这是一集经典的《办公室》。我要说这是一集经典的《办公室》。砰。好吧，安吉拉，自从这一集播出后我就没看过，我在看的时候确实发现了新的深刻之处。哦，是的。而且确实有一些台词和时刻让我印象深刻。
And I'll bring it up as we go through the episode. Same. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will break down the convict. We'll see ya. No frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC Optimum Points on your first five orders. Shop now at NoFriills.ca. To succeed in the future of work, forward thinkers use AI to deliver measurable results. Workday is the AI platform for HR and finance that frees you from the mundane so you can focus on more meaningful work.
当我们浏览这一集时，我会提出来的。我也是。好吧，我们休息一下吧？当我们回来时，我们将拆解《囚犯》。再见。No Frills送货上门。通过PC Express从No Frills将杂货送到您家门口。在线购物并在您的前五笔订单中获得15美元的PC Optimum积分。立即在NoFrills.ca购物。为了在未来的工作中取得成功，前瞻性思维者使用人工智能来提供可衡量的结果。Workday是人力资源和财务的人工智能平台，它将您从平凡的工作中解放出来，这样您就可以专注于更有意义的工作。
Workday. Moving business forever forward. Okay, so we are back. This episode starts with Hannah bringing her baby into the office. She is setting up for the, her baby's staying all day, clearly. She's got a pack and play. Yeah, there's a pack and play. I mean, she's, she's moving in. What's happening?
Workday。让业务永远向前发展。好的，我们回来了。这一集以汉娜带着她的宝宝来到办公室开始。她正在为她的宝宝准备，宝宝显然要待一整天。她有一个便携式婴儿床。是的，有一个便携式婴儿床。我是说，她搬进来了。发生了什么？
Yeah. We had a fan question from Ellis Friedman, Victoria Leva, and Megan Kiel. Why did Hannah bring her baby into the office? Yes, ladies. Why? Why? We don't know. I watched the deleted scenes. I have a lot to bring to this episode that is explained in deleted scenes. We'll get to that. This is not. There's a whole runner in the deleted scenes with the baby. There's no explanation. People holding the baby? Yeah.
是的。我们有一个来自埃利斯·弗里德曼、维多利亚·莱瓦和梅根·基尔的粉丝问题。为什么汉娜带她的宝宝来办公室？是的，女士们。为什么？为什么？我们不知道。我看了被删减的场景。我有很多关于这一集的内容要带给大家，这些内容在被删减的场景中有解释。我们会谈到的。这不是。被删减的场景里有一个关于宝宝的完整情节。没有解释。人们抱着宝宝？是的。
I saw that in the script because I have the script for this one. And there are all these scenes of people with the baby, but never is it explained why the baby is there. I would like to point out that this is a very progressive choice by Michael to allow a new mother to bring their baby into the office for the day. So I appreciate that.
我在剧本里看到了，因为我有这一集的剧本。有所有这些人们抱着宝宝的场景，但从来没有解释为什么宝宝在那里。我想指出，迈克尔允许新妈妈带宝宝来办公室待一天是一个非常进步的选择。所以我很欣赏这一点。
Although what we didn't need him to do was get under the table and do an impression of Look Who's Talking. Do you remember those movies? With Kirsty Alley and John Travolta? They were a huge hit. Wait, is Bruce Willis the talking baby? Yeah, Bruce Willis.
虽然我们不需要他钻到桌子底下模仿《看谁在说话》。你还记得那些电影吗？有柯斯蒂·艾利和约翰·特拉沃尔塔？它们非常受欢迎。等等，布鲁斯·威利斯是那个会说话的宝宝吗？是的，布鲁斯·威利斯。
So, Kirsty Alley has like a one night stand with this cab driver played by John Travolta. And they have a baby and now they have to figure out has like a one-night stand with this cab driver played by John Travolta and they have a baby and now they have to figure out how to I guess co-parent this baby when they're not a couple of course, spoiler alert, they're gonna fall in love. Yay! But all the while you're getting commentary on their parenting and their romance through the voice of the baby voiced by Bruce Willis. As a grown man.
所以，柯斯蒂·艾利和这个由约翰·特拉沃尔塔饰演的出租车司机发生了一夜情。他们有了一个宝宝，现在他们必须弄清楚，和这个由约翰·特拉沃尔塔饰演的出租车司机发生了一夜情，他们有了一个宝宝，现在他们必须弄清楚当他们不是情侣时如何共同抚养这个宝宝，当然，剧透警告，他们会坠入爱河。耶！但与此同时，你通过布鲁斯·威利斯配音的宝宝的声音，得到了关于他们的育儿和浪漫的评论。作为一个成年男人。
So, cause he's not doing a baby voice. He's a grown man voice and a baby voice. No, no, he's doing his own regular man voice. I wanna be in that pitch meeting. I wanna be in that pitch meeting. I wanna see the person that's like, here's the thing. The baby talks and it's Bruce Willis. The same guy that said Yippee-ki-yay mother-of-er is
所以，因为他没有用宝宝的声音。他是一个成年男人的声音和一个宝宝的声音。不，不，他用的是他自己正常的男人声音。我想参加那个推销会议。我想参加那个推销会议。我想看看那个说，事情是这样的。宝宝会说话，而且是布鲁斯·威利斯。那个说“Yippee-ki-yay mother-of-er”的同一个人
gonna be the baby. It's gonna be great. Here we go. Okay, well in the deleted scenes there is a baby runner. I mean, Karen holds the baby and flirts with Jim and Pam watches it all. I read that in the script. Mm-hmm. Kelly holds the baby and just jiggles it in front of Ryan. And Ryan finally is like, what Kelly, what? Are you holding a baby because you want me to want to have a baby with you? And she's like, no, what are you talking about? Whatever.
要成为宝宝。这会很棒。我们开始吧。好的，在被删减的场景中有一个宝宝情节。我是说，凯伦抱着宝宝和吉姆调情，帕姆看着这一切。我在剧本里读到了。嗯哼。凯莉抱着宝宝，只是在瑞安面前摇晃它。瑞安终于说，什么凯莉，什么？你抱着宝宝是因为你想让我想要和你生个孩子吗？她说，不，你在说什么？随便吧。
And then three seconds later, she's like, oh my God, I want a baby right now. It's actually really funny. And then there's a very funny deleted scene where Andy and Dwight have like a baby off. Like they're so ridiculous. These two are so ridiculous. Like Andy's like, I was a baby model.
然后三秒钟后，她说，哦，天哪，我现在想要个孩子。这其实真的很有趣。然后有一个非常有趣的被删减场景，安迪和德怀特进行了一场“宝宝比赛”。他们太荒谬了。这两个人太荒谬了。安迪说，我曾经是个宝宝模特。
Not gonna apologize for it. I was a beautiful baby and I modeled. This is like their whole competition in the last episode about who has seen more movies. Exactly. So they're arguing about themselves as babies. Andy was, I guess a gorgeous baby and modeled. And Dwight was like, well, I weighed 13 pounds
不会为此道歉。我是一个漂亮的宝宝，我当过模特。这就像他们上一集关于谁看过更多电影的竞争。完全正确。所以他们在争论自己作为宝宝的时候。安迪，我猜是一个漂亮的宝宝，当过模特。德怀特说，好吧，我重13磅
and my mom couldn't walk for three months, so take that. It's so weird. All right, well, the scene with Pam having to watch Jim and Karen fuss over this baby was deleted, but the next scene in the episode is Pam watching Jim and Karen kind of flirt at the copy machine. Yeah. And at one minute, 47 seconds, you can still see my zit
我妈妈三个月没法走路，所以受着吧。这太奇怪了。好吧，帕姆不得不看着吉姆和凯伦围着这个宝宝忙碌的场景被删减了，但这一集里的下一个场景是帕姆看着吉姆和凯伦在复印机旁调情。是的。在1分47秒，你仍然可以看到我的痘痘
from the week before. Stop it. From the merger. It's a little smaller, but it's still there. You have got to stop pointing it out. None of us noticed, or maybe Hadley did, because I know she noticed Dwight's zit. But Jenna, you like to track things. Stop
从前一周开始。停下。从合并那一集。它小了一点，但它还在那里。你必须停止指出它。我们都没注意到，或者也许哈德利注意到了，因为我知道她注意到了德怀特的痘痘。但珍娜，你喜欢追踪事情。停下
tracking your acne. Well, I think my it's going to be gone next week, but I mean, we'll see. We'll see. It'll make your list. I'm sure. All right. So then we have this, you know, Jim talking head, and he says that he is seeing Karen. He is he admits it, but he isn't ready to talk about it openly because he doesn't want some people, you know, treating them differently. I have a beef with Jim. I just wrote, not cool. Not cool. Yeah. This goes back to my wishy washy Jim. Yeah. Wishy washy Jim. There it is again. All right. So now we move into the conference room. We've got Angela, Kevin, Michael, and Pam. They are all on the speakerphone to Jan, and they are discussing this mysterious check that has
追踪你的痤疮。好吧，我想下周它就会消失了，但我是说，我们会看到的。我们会看到的。它会进入你的名单。我肯定。好的。所以我们有这个，你知道，吉姆的谈话片段，他说他正在和凯伦约会。他承认了，但他还没准备好公开谈论它，因为他不想让某些人，你知道，区别对待他们。我对吉姆有意见。我刚写了，不酷。不酷。是的。这回到了我那优柔寡断的吉姆。是的。优柔寡断的吉姆。它又出现了。好的。所以现在我们进入会议室。我们有安吉拉、凯文、迈克尔和帕姆。他们都在免提电话上和简通话，他们正在讨论这张神秘的支票，它有
arrived. Yeah, I have a question, Jenna. Yeah. I get why Michael's on the phone. I get why the accountants are. Why is Pam there? Is it just because Michael just likes to have Pam around? She's like keeper of the minutes or something. Yeah, he sees Pam as his personal assistant She is not his personal assistant. She is the receptionist But he doesn't have a personal assistant and so he sort of you know makes her play that role Yeah, she's always in these meetings. She shouldn't be in that's right always there's many episodes of meetings of Pam in conversations between Michael and Jan. And I love it because the camera will just like pan mid-scene and then it reveals Pam
到了。是啊，我有问题，珍娜。是啊。我明白迈克尔为什么在打电话。我明白会计们为什么在打电话。帕姆为什么在那儿？是因为迈克尔就是喜欢帕姆在身边吗？她就像会议记录员之类的。是啊，他把帕姆看作他的私人助理。她不是他的私人助理。她是前台。但他没有私人助理，所以他算是，你知道，让她扮演那个角色。是啊，她总是参加这些会议。她本不该参加的，没错，总是这样。有很多集里都有帕姆在迈克尔和简的谈话中。我喜欢这样，因为摄像机会在场景中间平移，然后露出帕姆。
has been sitting there with a notebook the whole time. I mean, she's always in these scenes. So awkward. I loved it. As an actress, I loved it. I bet. Jan eventually explains that this check is something that they're getting in exchange for hiring an ex-convict, which Michael is like, I didn't hire an ex-convict.
一直坐在那儿记笔记。我是说，她总是出现在这些场景里。太尴尬了。我喜欢。作为一名女演员，我喜欢这样。我敢打赌。简最终解释说，这张支票是他们雇佣了一名前科犯而得到的报酬，迈克尔说，我没有雇佣前科犯。
They come to realize that one of the Stanford transfers must be part of this program, meaning that there is someone from Stanford who has a criminal record. All right. So Jenna, when Jan said, oh, they're probably getting the tax break because they hired an X-Con, I was like, hold up. I know this program. Why did she just jump to X-Con?
他们意识到斯坦福转来的员工中肯定有人参与了这个项目，这意味着斯坦福来的人里有人有犯罪记录。好吧。那么珍娜，当简说，哦，他们可能因为雇佣了前科犯而获得了税收减免时，我就想，等等。我知道这个项目。她为什么直接跳到前科犯身上？
Because several people qualify for this program. Because I worked at a company that had employees that qualified for this federal work program. And guess what I did? Well, I'm sensing a deep dive here. Then you sensed right, lady. All right. I went on the US Department of Labor
因为有几类人符合这个项目的条件。因为我曾在一家公司工作，那里的员工符合这个联邦工作项目的条件。你猜我做了什么？好吧，我感觉到这里有个深度挖掘。那你感觉对了，女士。好吧。我上了美国劳工部。
and the IRS websites for like three hours. Real fun stuff there, guys. Real fun. I love you. And I deeply love you for that. I really do, Angela. I love that you did that. I know, because this is coming from someone who spent, I think probably five hours of her life researching an alpha womb. So go on. Anyway, so it is called the work opportunity tax credit.
和国税局的网站查了大约三个小时。很有趣的东西，伙计们。真的很有趣。我爱你。我为此深深地爱你。我真的爱你，安吉拉。我喜欢你这样做。我知道，因为这话出自一个我想大概花了她人生五个小时研究阿尔法子宫的人之口。所以继续吧。总之，它被称为工作机会税收抵免。
It's a federal tax credit available to employees for hiring individuals from certain targeted groups who have consistently faced significant barriers to employment. And there are several types of people that qualify for this program. There are veterans, all right, there are recipients of SNAP benefits, which is food stamps, people with supplemental security income, people that have long term unemployment. So a lot of people qualify for this, not just ex cons. And the companies that hire this group, depending on the hours they work,
这是一项联邦税收抵免，提供给雇佣来自特定目标群体、一直面临重大就业障碍的个人的雇主。有几类人符合这个项目的条件。有退伍军人，好吧，有SNAP福利（即食品券）的领取者，有补充保障收入的人，有长期失业的人。所以很多人都符合这个条件，不仅仅是前科犯。而雇佣这些群体的公司，取决于他们的工作时长，
there's like certain categories they have to check off the list, but your company can get a tax credit anywhere from 2400 to $9,600 per employee you hire through this program. Wow. Yeah. Oh, am I getting applause for my deep dive?
他们必须勾选清单上的某些类别，但你的公司通过这个项目每雇佣一名员工，可以获得2400到9600美元不等的税收抵免。哇。是啊。哦，我是因为我的深度挖掘而得到掌声吗？
That was a really well done deep dive, lady. You deep and you dive and you deep in a dive. What was your song? Your son made up. You get a deep, you get a dive, put them together, get a deep dive. Well, Angela, I have a beef with Jan, right? Because all of us ask like, oh, who is it? Who's the ex-convict? And she's like, Hold on a second. I'll find out. You'll find out. What Jan? What are you
那是一次非常出色的深度挖掘，女士。你深挖、深挖、再深挖。你的歌是什么？你儿子编的。你深挖，你潜水，合在一起，就是深度挖掘。好吧，安吉拉，我对简有意见，对吧？因为我们所有人都问，哦，是谁？谁是前科犯？她说，等一下。我会查出来的。你会查出来的。简，你要干什么？
going to tell this conference room full of people? This like private personal, this feels like an HR violation to me. Toby, where are you? Toby, where are you? Jan, you would have to go to a special HR meeting because you just crossed the line, lady. I feel like she crosses the line by giving out this information. But while we are on hold, everyone starts trying to guess who is it.
你要告诉这满会议室的人吗？这感觉像是侵犯了人力资源规定。托比，你在哪儿？托比，你在哪儿？简，你得去参加一个特别的人力资源会议，因为你刚刚越界了，女士。我觉得她泄露这些信息就是越界了。但在我们等待的时候，大家开始猜测是谁。
Michael guesses basically, they're just looking out in the bullpen at who they can see, Hannah, Andy. Then Kevin says Martin, and Michael's like, how dare you? He goes, you just said that because you think Martin is black. And Kevin is like, Well, no, he he is black. So they're kind of bickering about it. And then Jan comes on the phone and she's
迈克尔基本上是在猜，他们只是看着办公区里能看到的人，汉娜，安迪。然后凯文说是马丁，迈克尔说，你怎么敢？他说，你这么说只是因为你觉得马丁是黑人。凯文说，嗯，不，他确实是黑人。所以他们就在那儿争论。然后简在电话里说。
like, It's Martin Nash. They're all wondering, Well, what did Martin do? Yeah. Why did he why was he in jail? And now Jenna, we are coming up to this line that Michael has you and I talked about it. It really stood out to us in light of the Black Lives Matter movement. Yes. This is when Michael says to us, a Black man can be arrested for just about anything in this country. Yeah.
她说，是马丁·纳什。他们都在想，马丁做了什么？是啊。他为什么坐牢？现在珍娜，我们要讲到迈克尔说的那句台词了，你和我讨论过。鉴于“黑人的命也是命”运动，它真的很突出。是的。这是迈克尔对我们说，在这个国家，一个黑人几乎可以因为任何事情被捕。是啊。
Yeah. I mean, we were rewatching this episode in the middle of a civil rights movement in our country. People are literally in the streets protesting this very fact of black people being arrested for just about anything, but not just that, being killed. So yeah, this line hit me hard. And I have to say, I expected Michael to make a joke here,
是啊。我是说，我们是在我国民权运动期间重温这一集的。人们真的在街上抗议黑人几乎因为任何事情被捕这一事实，不仅如此，还有被杀害。所以，是的，这句台词深深触动了我。我必须说，我以为迈克尔会在这里开个玩笑，
but he doesn't. No, he doesn't. make a joke here, but he doesn't. No, he doesn't. And I'm so glad that he doesn't. I know, me too. Well, you know, I think, Jenna, as the viewer, we're always expecting Michael to play it up for the cameras, right? He thinks he's like an entertainer. And anyway, but he doesn't in this moment. He's just truthful and sincere.
但他没有。不，他没有。在这里开玩笑，但他没有。不，他没有。我很高兴他没有。我知道，我也是。嗯，你知道，我认为，珍娜，作为观众，我们总是期待迈克尔在镜头前表演，对吧？他认为自己是个艺人。总之，但在这一刻他没有。他只是真实而诚恳。
And I think it made the line that much more powerful. Yeah, I agree. I agree. And you know, also, while we were prepping this episode, I was reading the book Just Mercy by Bryan Stevenson. And it's an amazing book. It's a memoir. It's about the story of this lawyer, Brian Stevenson,
我认为这让这句台词更有力量。是啊，我同意。我同意。而且你知道，在准备这一集的时候，我正在读布莱恩·史蒂文森的《正义的慈悲》。这是一本很棒的书。这是一本回忆录。它讲述了律师布莱恩·史蒂文森的故事，
and how he helps to overturn the sentence of a man who's on death row for a crime he didn't commit. But it also goes into ways that our criminal justice system is in need of reform. And it's just, it's a really powerful book. And I feel like I learned so much. We can actually, we can link to it in our show notes, but just to rewatch this episode right now and hear that line, I mean, it just, yeah, it had a lot, it had a lot of added poignancy for me. Yeah, for me too. I know Just Mercy is also a movie that's out now, but Jenna, you love the book so much and you're sending it my way. So thank you. I am. Yes, I'm giving you my copy. Thanks. Okay. So getting back to the scene, what happens next? Okay. So next Michael tells them, you know what? Do not share this information. No one needs to know
以及他如何帮助推翻了一名因未犯下的罪行而被判死刑的男子的判决。但它也探讨了我们的刑事司法系统需要改革的方式。这真是一本非常有力量的书。我觉得我学到了很多。我们实际上可以在节目笔记中链接它，但现在重温这一集并听到那句台词，我的意思是，它确实，它对我来说增加了许多辛酸。是啊，对我也是。我知道《正义的慈悲》现在也是一部电影，但珍娜，你非常喜欢这本书，而且你要把它送给我。所以谢谢你。我是。是的，我要把我的那本给你。谢谢。好吧。回到场景，接下来发生了什么？好吧。接下来迈克尔告诉他们，你知道吗？不要分享这个信息。没人需要知道。
about this. Yes. I mean, he's oddly the voice of reason in this moment. He's like, it's no one's business. It's not a good thing to share, right? Kevin says, cool. Pam's like, okay, Angela, I have a hard time with that. SONIA DARA GERMES Angela needs to know what was the crime. RISA GOLUBOFF Right. And she's also very, you know, she's not a very trusting person. She's a very fear-based person. And she starts to spiral out. SONIA DARA GERMES Well, she's also not a very forgiving person. I mean, don't make a mistake around Angela. She'll remember it forever.
关于这个。是的。我是说，他在这一刻奇怪地成了理性的声音。他说，这不关任何人的事。这不是什么好事，对吧？凯文说，酷。帕姆说，好吧，安吉拉，我对此感到很难受。安吉拉需要知道罪行是什么。没错。而且她也是一个，你知道，她不是一个很信任别人的人。她是一个非常基于恐惧的人。她开始失控。嗯，她也不是一个很宽容的人。我是说，别在安吉拉身边犯错。她会永远记住的。
And it's no surprise to me that Dwight has a similar reaction because the two of them are, you know, they're soulmates. And so they both spiral out. But we'll get to that. All right. So next, we're out in the bullpen and Andy calls Jim. And this is what I wrote on my card, Jenna. Why does Jim even entertain this conversation?
德怀特有类似的反应我一点也不惊讶，因为他们俩是，你知道，灵魂伴侣。所以他们俩都失控了。但我们稍后再说。好吧。接下来，我们在办公区，安迪给吉姆打电话。这就是我在卡片上写的，珍娜。为什么吉姆还要应付这个谈话？
He calls him on the phone because he wants to know which woman in the office he should hit on. And he like starts naming all the women. And I agree. Why does Jim not just hang up? I think Jim sort of sees a way to prank Pam. I don't think he wants to be part of Andy's grossness, but he suggests Pam.
他打电话给他是因为他想知道办公室里的哪个女人他应该搭讪。他开始列举所有的女人。我同意。为什么吉姆不直接挂断？我觉得吉姆算是看到了一个捉弄帕姆的方法。我不认为他想参与安迪的恶心行为，但他提到了帕姆。
Yes. So next up, Michael takes Dwight aside to tell him about Martin's past. And Dwight has this talking head where he explains that he is upset simply because he does not like criminals. He doesn't like criminals. And we had a fan question from Mary Coors, Nicole Bridges,
是的。接下来，迈克尔把德怀特拉到一边告诉他马丁的过去。德怀特有一个谈话头，他解释说他心烦仅仅是因为他不喜欢罪犯。他不喜欢罪犯。我们收到了来自玛丽·库尔斯、妮可·布里奇斯和杰特·芬顿的粉丝提问。在迈克尔告诉德怀特马丁是前科犯后，他在窗前有一个谈话头。但通常他的谈话头都是面向办公室的。为什么这次变了？好吧，自从我们分享了关于窗户的事情后，人们真的一直在追踪谈话头的位置。
and Jett Fenton. After Michael tells Dwight about Martin being a convict, he has this talking head in front of a window. But normally his talking heads are facing into the office. Why the change now? OK, people have really been tracking where the talking heads are and the whole window thing ever since we shared about it.
所以我只想把这件事平息。这是因为这是那种即兴的谈话头。这是在办公室入口处邓德·米夫林标志旁边的窗户。这不是在会议室里完成的。这不是正式的谈话头。如果是的话，我相信他们会把德怀特坐在那张椅子上，背后是办公区。
So I just want to put this one to rest. This is because this is one of those on-the-fly talking heads. This is next to the window that's next to our Dunder Mifflin sign in the little lobby as you walk into the office. This was not done in the conference room. This was not a formal talking head. If it was, I'm sure they would have sat Dwight down in that same chair with the bullpen behind him.
但既然这是即兴的，那就是那扇窗户。它并不代表我们之前的谈话头主题。所以象征意义发生在会议室，而不是即兴的谈话头。没错。所以德怀特，像安吉拉一样，开始因为这个信息而失控。他要试图查个水落石出。是的，德怀特和安吉拉都因为不知道马丁为什么坐牢而心神不宁。他们无法放下，就像迈克尔建议的那样。与此同时，安迪正在盘问吉姆帕姆的兴趣是什么。吉姆列举了所有这些疯狂的事情。其中一个，安迪真的抓住了，那就是“Frolf”，飞盘高尔夫。是的。是的。很明显，吉姆实际上列举了所有帕姆讨厌的事情，
But since this was on the fly, that's what that window is. It is not significant of our previous talking head theme. So the symbolism happens in the conference room, not so much talking head on the fly. Right. So Dwight, like Angela, starts to spiral out with this information. He's going to try to get to the bottom of things. Yes, both Dwight and Angela are preoccupied with the fact that they don't know why Martin was in prison. They can't let it go, like Michael suggested. And meanwhile, Andy is quizzing Jim about what are Pam's interests. And Jim lists off all of these crazy things. One of them, Andy really jumps on, which is frulf, frisbee golf. Yes. Yes. It becomes very clear that Jim is actually listing all of the things that Pam hates,
但把它们呈现为帕姆喜欢的事情。他说，任何基于飞盘的比赛。安迪说，天哪，我想他在大学时发明了某种飞盘和高尔夫的结合体。不，他没有发明它。他在队里。他在康奈尔玩过Frolf。安迪没说他发明了Frolf。我想他说了。走开。我想他说他是康奈尔Frolf队的创始人之一。康奈尔的队，但不是这项运动。这是一项真正的运动。不，不，不，安吉拉。等等。
but presenting them as the things that Pam loves. And he says, any frisbee-based competition. To which Andy says, oh my gosh, I guess he invented some sort of combination of frisbee and golf while he was in college No, he didn't invent it. He was on the team. He played froth at Cornell Andy doesn't say he invented froth. I think he did be gone I think he says he was one of the founders of the froth team at Cornell Cornell's team, but not of the sport It's an actual sport. No, no, no Angela. Wait
不是这项运动。这是一项真正的运动。不，不，不。安吉拉，等等。等等。是的，它是。我以为那是编出来的。Frolfing？不。不，没有那种同时玩飞盘和高尔夫的东西。那不可能是真的。是的。住手。是的，有，珍娜。所以安迪，安迪只是说他在康奈尔创立了这支队伍。他是创始成员。我深度挖掘了Frolf。而且，我丈夫说，是的，飞盘高尔夫。我喜欢飞盘高尔夫。我说，等等，什么？他说，是的，你在公园里玩。我没有谷歌搜索Frolf。
not of the sport. It's an actual sport. No, no, no. Angela, wait. Wait. Yes, it is. I thought that was made up. Frothing? No. No, there is not something where you play Frisbee and golf at the same time. That cannot be true. Yes. Stop it. Yes, there is, Jenna. So Andy, Andy is just saying that he founded the team at Cornell. He is a founding member. I did a deep dive on Frolf. Also, my husband was like, yeah, Frisbee golf. I love Frisbee golf. I was like, wait, what? He was like, yeah, you play it in the park. I did not Google Frolf
因为我觉得那不可能是真的。它是真的，珍娜。天哪。它是真的。你可以去，去YouTube。天哪。我去了eHow的YouTube频道。
because I thought there is no possible way that is a real thing. It's a real thing, Jon. Oh my gosh. It's a real thing. You can go on, go on YouTube. Oh my gosh. And I went on the eHow YouTube channel
基本上你有一个飞盘，你必须把它扔进篮子里。全国各地都有场地。你实际上可以去职业飞盘高尔夫协会的网站。那是PDGA。你可以查到你所在地区、你所在城市哪里有飞盘高尔夫球场。这是一整套东西，珍娜。
and basically you have a Frisbee and you have to throw it in a basket. There's courses all across the country. You can actually go to the Professional Disc Golf Association website. That's the PDGA. And you can find out where there are Frisbee golf courses in your area, in your city. And it's a whole thing, Jenna.
哇。是啊。好吧，我刚刚谷歌了Frolf，我正在读frolf.com。这是我目前读到的最喜欢的东西。世界上每个人和每件事都是Frolfing游戏的一部分。每一棵树、街道、标志、建筑物、汽车、人、动物，一切都是游戏的一部分。玩一洞时必须考虑一切。哇。我玩过飞盘高尔夫，我在大学毕业后在纽约中央公园玩过。我会说，好吧，现在我们不在像PDGA那样有篮子的公园里。但我们只是说，好吧，你必须达到的第一个洞是在那两棵树之间。然后你必须把它弄到那个喷泉上。然后你必须把它弄到那个公园长椅上。你可以在任何地方玩Frolf，珍娜，任何地方。你可以在你的后院玩Frolf。
Wow. Yeah. Well, I just Googled frolf and I'm reading on frolf.com. This is my favorite thing I've read so far. Everyone and everything in the world is part of a frolfing game. Every tree, street, sign, building, car, person, animal, everything is a part of the game. Everything must be taken into consideration when playing a hole. Wow. I have played Frisbee golf and I played it like out of college in New
自己建个球场，珍娜。我仍然觉得这太疯狂了，我，有一小部分我确信你已经在互联网上植入了所有的Frolfing网站，只是为了现在捉弄我。好吧，那绝对是我会做的事。不，很抱歉这么说。好吧，哇。老实说，我的大脑被震撼了。
York in Central Park and I'd be like, okay, now we weren't on a course like the PDGA where there's like a park with the baskets. But we were just like, OK, the first the first hole that you have to get is like between those two trees. And then you've got to get it onto that fountain. And then you've got to get it onto that park bench. You can play froth anywhere, Jenna, anywhere. You can play froth in your backyard.
Frolfing是真实存在的。好吧，这里还有更多我们学到的帕姆讨厌的事情，吉姆却把它们呈现为她喜欢的事情。狩猎，带老人的六旗广告。你记得那些吗？我记得，我记得。我记得。
Make your own course, Jenna. It's still so insane to me that I, like, there's a part, there's a very, very tiny part of me that is convinced that you have planted all of the Frolfing websites on the internet just to like prank me right now. Well that's, that is absolutely something I would do. Not, I'm sorry to say. All right, wow. Honestly, my mind is blown
那是一个化着非常诡异的老年妆的家伙。他其实并不老，对吧？他覆盖着这种乳胶妆，他做了这种激烈的舞蹈。他会跳霹雳舞。很诡异。是啊。是啊，很诡异。
at that for all thing is a real thing. Okay, here are more of the things that we learned that Pam hates that Jim presents as things she loves. Hunting, ads for six flags with the old man. Do you remember those? I do, I do. I do.
还有猪拉丁语。我和我丈夫谈论了猪拉丁语。当你谈论像“把工作带回家”时。这就像，我说，宝贝，你玩飞盘高尔夫吗？宝贝，你会说猪拉丁语吗？显然我一直做错了。震惊，不震惊。哦，等等，我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问，安吉拉。
It was a guy in like really creepy old age makeup. He wasn't actually old, right? He was covered in this latex makeup and he did this like intense dancing. He would like break dance. It was creepy. Yeah. Yeah, it was creepy.
德米特里亚想知道，你在现实生活中会说猪拉丁语吗？安吉拉，你以为你会。嗯，我和我的朋友们，我们做了我们的猪拉丁语版本，但当我在线查的时候，网上说它是前两个辅音。好吧。我们只是取每个单词的第一个字母。
And then also Pig Latin. I got in a conversation with my husband about Pig Latin. When you talk about like, bring your work home. This was like, I'm like, babe, do you play Frisbee golf? Babe, do you speak Pig Latin? Apparently I've been doing it wrong. Shocker, not a shocker. Oh, well wait, we had a fan question about this, Angela.
我们就是这么做的。我们取第一个字母，加到最后，再加一个Y。但当我在线查的时候，它说是前两个辅音。你们是那样做的吗？嗯，一个有两个辅音的单词的例子是什么？Thought（思想）。Authtay。
Demetria wants to know, can you speak Pig Latin in real life? Angela, you thought you could. Well, my friends and I, we did our version of Pig Latin, but then when I looked it up online, online it says it's the first two consonants. Okay. And we just did the first letter of each word.
你怎么说Authtay？好吧，我和我的朋友们会说Haute。哦，那太错了。你们知道自己在说什么吗？你们能听懂对方吗？你们说拉丁语费劲吗？不，我们玩得很开心。我们很好。这对你们来说更隐秘，因为其他人听不懂你们的猪拉丁语。所以
That's how we did it. We did the first letter, add it to the end and add a Y. But when I looked it up online, it said it's the first two consonants. Is that how you guys do it? Well, what is an example of a word with two consonants? Thought. Authtay.
你怎么说There？Are they？好吧，我们会说Heretay。哇。嗯，我和我的朋友们，我们实际上……Ooday, ooyay。我们说一种叫“ob”语言的东西。什么？它叫“ob”语言。我朋友莎拉·奥哈洛兰的母亲教了她“ob”语言。所以莎拉的名字在“ob”里会是Sabaraba Abahabalabarabin。住手。住手。
How would you say authtay? Okay, so my friends and I would say haute. Oh, that's so wrong. Did you guys know what you were saying? Did you guys understand each other? Did you struggle speaking Latin? No, we had a fine time. We were fine. It was even more secretive for you because other people could not understand your Pig Latin. So
那一直是我最喜欢说的话。住手。住手。那一直是我最喜欢说的话。住手。那太荒谬了。所以你在听到的每个元音前加一个“ab”音。所以像“really”这样的词拼写是R-E-A，但你不在E前和A前加“ab”。你只是在元音前加它。所以“really”这个词会是Rabalabi。
how would you say there? Are they? Okay, so we would say heretay. Wow. Well, my friends and I, we actually... Ooday, ooyay. We spoke something called the ob language. What? It's called the ob language. My friend Sarah O'Halloran's mother taught her the ob language. So Sarah's name in ob would be Sabaraba Abahabalabarabin. Stop it. Stop it.
等等。Abba tabba rabalabi kabalabengwabbage。Abba mabayfraband sabarabba abahabbalababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababab元音。所以“really”这个词会是Rabba labi。好吧，这太荒谬了。你的朋友能听懂你并说回来吗？你们会那样走来走去说话吗？我们太酷了。我们太酷了。所以我的名字会是Abang Abaloba吗？不，你的名字会是Abalad Angela Abalad。天哪。你怎么说Angela？
That was always my favorite thing to say. Stop it. Stop it. That was always my favorite thing to say. Stop it. That's ridiculous. So you put an ab sound before every vowel sound that you hear. So a word like really is spelled R-E-A, but you don't put ab before the E and before the A. You just put it before the vowel sound. So the word really would be rabalabi.
Abang Abanjab。Kabin Zabi。Kabin Zabi？那是Kinsey吗？我的名字是Jabba Nabba Fabba Shabber。天哪！好吧，好吧。好吧，好吧。我们在这一集的什么地方？好吧，所以我对吉姆和安迪的这个场景有几个粉丝提问。
Wait a second. Abba tabba rabalabi kabalabengwabbage. Abba mabayfraband sabarabba abahabbalababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababab vowel sound. So the word really would be rabba labi. Okay, this is ridiculous. And could your friend understand you and speak it back? And would you guys walk around talking like that? We were so cool. We were so cool. So would my name be Abang Abaloba? No, your name would be Abalad Angela Abalad. Oh my gosh. How do you say Angela?
准备好了吗？OK。来自莎拉·霍奇斯、利兹·佛朗哥、瑞秋·海耶斯和唐娜·米勒的粉丝提问。帕姆讨厌的任何事情是珍娜也讨厌的吗？她们想知道，我是否参与了吉姆选择的项目？不，我没有对那个清单提供任何咨询。
Abang Abanjab. Kabin Zabi. Kabin Zabi? Is that Kinsey? My name is Jabba Nabba Fabba Shabber. Oh my god! Alright, alright. Okay, okay. Where are we in this episode? Alright, so I have a couple of fan questions from this scene with Jim and Andy.
显然，因为你根本不知道。我根本不知道。我甚至不知道什么是Frolfing。飞盘高尔夫是真实存在的。所以我不知道。我讨厌它，因为我不知道。然后，我们还有一个谜团。许多人写信询问6分50秒的这个谜团。
Are you ready? OK. Fan question from Sarah Hodges, Liz Franco, Rachel Hayes, and Donna Miller. Are any of the things that Pam hates, things that Jenna hates too, they want to know, did I get to collaborate on what items Jim chose? No, I did not give any consultation on that list.
克里斯托弗·杰克、唐娜·米勒再次写信。艾米·克鲁兹和切尔西·凯都写信说：“看起来吉姆肩膀后的桌子上有一个迷你壁炉加热器。那是什么？”好吧，看起来确实有，我不知道那是什么，但我被它迷住了。
Clearly, because you had no idea. I had no idea. I don't even know what frothing is. The Frisbee golf was a real thing. So I didn't know that. I hated it, because I didn't know. And then also, we have a mystery. Many people wrote in about this mystery at 6 minutes and 50
迷住了，伙计们，去6分50秒看看。那是什么？我把它写在卡片上，因为我想去查一下。看起来像是一个有灯的小加热器，你知道，然后它吹出那个小东西，看起来像火焰。是啊。
seconds. Christopher Jake, Donna Miller, again. Amy Cruz and Chelsea Kay all wrote in to say, "'It looks like there is a mini fireplace heater in the background on a desk over Jim's shoulder. What is it?' Okay, there really does look, I don't know what it is, but I was mesmerized by it.
奇怪。看起来它放在卢安以前总是坐的那张桌子上。天哪。就在托比桌子前面。卢安桌子上以前放的东西之一是一个小禅园。你记得吗？我想知道那是不是它。我想知道是否有光从她的禅园反射出来。
Mesmerized, guys, go to six minutes and 50 seconds. What is it? I'm writing this down on a note card because I wanna go check it out. It looks like there is a little heater that has a light, you know, and then it blows the little, you know, thing to look like a flame. Yeah.
可能是。她有像小沙子和耙子。是啊。好吧，在7分17秒，迈克尔做了他做的那件事，伙计们。他无法保守秘密。你不能告诉他任何事。
Weird. It looks like it's sitting on that desk where Luanne always used to sit. Oh my God. Right in front of Toby's desk. One of the things that used to sit on Luanne's desk was a little zen garden. Do you remember? And I wondered if that's what it was. I wondered if there was some light reflecting off
他无法保守它。就像迈克尔不得不向大家宣布奥斯卡是同性恋一样，迈克尔现在觉得他在帮忙。他认为他在帮忙。他只是要说，嘿，让我们坦白吧。而且，你知道，他让每个人都知道了马丁的过去。这是一个很棒的场景，因为他走到马丁的桌子前，说，嘿，我只是想过来问问，你适应得怎么样？马丁说，哦，是的，谢谢你过来。我适应得很好。然后他立刻说，大家注意，我只是想让你们知道马丁是个前科犯，但我信任他，你们不准评判他。
of her zen garden. It could be. She had like a little sand and a ray. Yeah. OK, so at 7 minutes, 17 seconds, Michael does the thing that he does, you guys. He cannot hold on to information. You can't tell him anything.
韦恩脸上的表情太棒了，因为他显然在想，我很抱歉，我以为我们在闲聊。现在显然我们在对我的过去做一个盛大的宣布。我是说，韦恩的反应太好了。这就是卖点。我们问他与史蒂夫演这些场景以及这些大型办公区场景是什么感觉。这就是他要说的。当时的节目非常受欢迎。史蒂夫是个大明星，这太疯狂了，因为他只是史蒂夫。你知道，你是联邦快递广告里的那个家伙，不是吗？
He won't be able to hold on to it. Much like how Michael had to announce to everyone that Oscar was gay, Michael now feels like he's helping. He thinks he's helping. He's just gonna say, hey, let's just come clean. And, you know, he lets everyone know of Martin's past. It's an amazing scene because he walks over
但是的，我看了这个节目，我也看了英国版。我是这个节目的忠实粉丝。这是台前幕后所有人的高质量工作。你可以看出你有一种感觉，它将成为一个历史性的节目，并将存在很长时间。所以成为它的一部分感觉真的很好。但走进片场，每个人都那么好，那么热情。每个人都知道他们手里拿着多么棒的东西。
to Martin's desk and he's like, hey, I just wanted to come over and say, how are you settling in? And Martin's like, oh yeah, thanks for coming over. I'm settling in fine. And then he immediately says, attention everyone, I just want you to know that Martin is an ex-convict, but I trust him and you're not allowed to judge him.
那种即兴表演是我最喜欢的即兴表演，那种微妙的、低调的东西在镜头前表现得最好。那里的每个人都非常擅长，他们已经成为了这台运转良好的机器。跳进去玩玩感觉很好。所以是的，那很棒。我认为那是真的。我真的觉得在节目的这个时候，
And the look on Wayne's face is so amazing because he's clearly like, I'm so sorry, I thought we were making small talk. And now apparently we're making a grand announcement about my past. I mean, Wayne's reaction is so good. It's what sells it. And we asked him what it was like to do these scenes with Steve and do these big sort of bullpen scenes. And here's what he had to say. The show at that time was getting hugely popular. Steve was a huge star, which was just wild, because it was just Steve. You know, you're the guy from the FedEx commercials,
我们就像这台机器，演员、剧组和编剧，我们真的融合在一起了。当我重温它时，我能感觉到，我能看到。你知道我不知道的是，安吉拉，史蒂夫在那些联邦快递广告里。哦，是的。我去谷歌搜索了它们。有很多。他就像，有像Verizon的家伙。
aren't you? But yeah, I watched the show, and I watched the British version as well. I was a big fan of the show. It was really quality work by all people in front and behind the camera. You could tell that you had this feeling it was going to be a historic show and it was going to be around for a long time. So it felt really good to be a part of it. But walking on set, everybody was so nice, so welcoming. Everybody knew what a great thing they had on their hands.
然后有Progressive的Flo。史蒂夫是联邦快递的家伙。是啊，我不知道这个。你是认真的吗？我让萨姆剪了一个片段。所以邦特蛋糕很糟糕。邦特蛋糕很糟糕，但你没抓住故事的重点。
That kind of improv is my favorite improv, that subtle understated thing that's best done on camera. And everybody there was so good at it and they were already becoming this well-oiled machine. It was nice to sort of to jump in and play. So yeah, that's pretty great. I think that's true. I really feel like at this time on the show,
整个员工都食物中毒了，留下包裹要寄送，截止日期要赶，只有一个销售经理来做这一切。只有一个？一个。他一个？一个。他吃了丹麦酥。跟我来。他跳上FedEx.com。
we were just this machine, like the cast and the crew and the writers, we had really gelled. And as I rewatch it, I can feel that and I can see it. You know what I didn't know, Angela, was that Steve was in those FedEx commercials. Oh yeah. And I went and I googled them. And there's like a ton. He was like how there's like a Verizon guy.
他在寄送，他在追踪，在手机、寻呼机、PDA上获得确认。他有PDA？每个人都有PDA。尽管如此，包裹到达了，他战胜了逆境。我不知道PDA。给你。
And then there's Flo from Progressive. Like Steve was the FedEx guy. Yeah, I did not know this. Are you serious? And I asked Sam to pull a clip. So the Bundt cake was bad. The Bundt cake was abysmal, but you're missing the point of the story.
好吧，等等，关于萨姆刚刚播放的那个特定的联邦快递广告，我有一个琐事。什么？我想让你们知道，史蒂夫说办公室里的每个人都食物中毒了。在这个广告里第一个跑去厕所呕吐的人是埃里克·斯通斯崔特。
The entire staff has food poisoning, leaving packages to be shipped, deadlines to be met, and one sales manager to do it all. Just one? One. He one? One. He had the Danish. Stay with me. He jumps on FedEx.com.
什么？那太疯狂了。他是这个广告里的临时演员，他跑去厕所呕吐。在《摩登家庭》里的埃里克·斯通斯崔特，在这个广告里是一个呕吐的员工。我喜欢这个。天哪，那太棒了。
He's shipping, he's tracking, getting confirmations on his cell phone, his pagers, PDA. He's got a PDA? Everybody's got a PDA. Nevertheless, packages arrive, he triumphs over adversity. I don't know PDA. There you go.
好吧，也在这个场景里，在迈克尔向整个办公室宣布马丁是前科犯后，他然后挑战每个人说出一个他们信任的白人，他会说出一个他更信任的黑人。所以他说，帕姆，说出一个你信任的白人。她说，我爸爸。他说，丹尼·格洛弗。
Well, wait, I have a piece of trivia about that specific FedEx ad that Sam just played. What? I want you guys to know, Steve is saying that everyone in the office got food poisoning. The first person that runs to the bathroom to puke in this commercial is Eric Stone Street.
在剧本里，有一个马丁的谈话头。我不知道这是否在删除场景里，安吉拉，但它让我大笑出声。太搞笑了。马丁说，迈克尔是个好人。他告诉我他比信任克尔斯滕·邓斯特更信任我。从来没有人这样告诉过我。我太喜欢那个谈话头了。
What? That's crazy. He's an extra in this commercial and he's running to the bathroom to puke. Eric Stone Street, who's on Modern Family, is in this commercial as a puking employee. I love that. Oh my gosh, that's amazing.
它只有三句话，但信息量非常丰富。那是在删除场景里吗？我能看那个谈话头吗？不，它不在删除场景里。我真的很伤心。删除场景里有一个马丁的谈话头。就是这个。他说，通常当人们发现监狱的事情时，是的，他们会变得很奇怪。那是个好东西。好吧，珍娜，现在我们在休息室，我们发现了马丁为什么坐牢。是的，马丁说，你们想知道我为什么坐牢吗？他解释说他因为内幕交易坐牢。现在我们进入了一个我喜欢的凯文谈话头。
All right, so also in the scene, after Michael announces to the entire office that Martin is an ex-convict, he then challenges everyone to name a white man they trust, and he will name a black man he trusts even more. So he's like, Pam, name a white man you trust. And she says, my dad. And he says, Danny Glover.
我大笑出声。他说，我让马丁解释了三次他为什么坐牢，因为它听起来很像我每天在这里办公室做的事情。是的，珍娜，网上有一个完整的理论，说邓德·米夫林是一个幌子，像一个洗钱的幌子。是的，有。有。而且也许我和凯文以及会计们参与其中。所以这里有一个来自托马斯·奥布莱恩的粉丝提问。他说他知道这个理论。主要原因是斯克兰顿的表现一直优于所有其他分部，
In the script, there is a Martin talking head. And I don't know if this is in the deleted scenes, Angela, but it made me laugh out loud. It was so funny. Martin says, Michael's an all right guy. He told me he trusts me more than Kirsten Dunst. And no one's ever told me that before. I love that talking head so much.
尽管纸张市场在迅速萎缩。托马斯想知道，我们对这个理论怎么看？我们认为邓德·米夫林实际上是洗钱的幌子有道理吗？我会说不，我不认为它真的是洗钱的幌子。我是说，如果那是故事的一部分，我相信格雷格·丹尼尔斯会在结局或最后一季的某个地方向我们揭示这一点。所以不，但我很好奇。听起来凯文确实参与了某种……某种阴暗的事情。是啊，对吧？因为这就是它。这是内幕交易。不是洗钱。
It is three sentences, but it is so rich with information. And was that in the deleted scenes? Can I see that talking head or no? No, it's not in the deleted scenes. And I'm really sad. There is a Martin talking head in the deleted scenes. And it's this one. He says, usually when people find out about the prison thing, yeah, they get pretty weird. That's a good one. All right, Jenna, now we're in the break room and we find out why Martin went to prison. Yes, Martin says, do you guys want to know what I was in for? And he explains that he went to prison for insider trading. Now we move into a Kevin talking head that I love.
马丁不是因为洗钱坐牢的。他是因为内幕交易坐牢的。我知道，但这是网上的理论，说邓德·米夫林是洗钱的幌子。他是因为内幕交易坐牢的。我知道，但这是网上的理论，说邓德·米夫林是洗钱的幌子。我会说我能看出来。哦，不，我能看出来。我能看出来。因为如果你要有一个洗钱的幌子，顺便说一句，我也一直在看很多《黑钱胜地》。这就是他做的。如果你看《黑钱胜地》，他必须为贩毒集团洗钱。所以我说，天哪，是的，一家纸业公司。而且你必须，你有所有这些库存，然后你有一个有点无能的老板，他可能不会发现所有事情。
I laughed out loud. He says, I asked Martin to explain why he went to jail three times because it sounds a lot like what I do every day here at the office. Yes, Jenna, there's a whole theory online that Dunder Mifflin is a front, like a money laundering front. Yes, there is. There is. And that maybe Kevin and I and the accountants are in on it. So here's a fan question from Thomas O'Brien. He says that he knows about this theory. And the main reason for this is that Scranton consistently outperforms all the other branches
对吧？我想我，我能看出来，托马斯。我能看出来。但我也在看《黑钱胜地》，所以也许那是我的信息来源。好吧。嗯，在这个场景里，马丁回答了我们所有人关于监狱生活是什么样的问题。他给出了一个相当乐观的监狱观。他说，哦，是的，我们有户外时间。我们可以看电视。我还可以上一些课。帕姆说，监狱里有水彩画课？
despite the rapidly decreasing paper market. And Thomas wants to know, what do we think about this theory? Do we think it has any merit that Dunder Mifflin is actually a front for money laundering? I would say no, I don't think it really is a front for money laundering. I mean, if that was a part of the story, I believe Greg Daniels would have revealed that to us
是啊。然后我们说，哇，迈克尔，听起来监狱比邓德·米夫林好。我们是在取笑迈克尔，对吧？然后迈克尔对邓德·米夫林比监狱差的暗示感到非常难过。你必须记住的是，邓德·米夫林的每个人都是迈克尔的家人，邓德·米夫林就像他远离家乡的家。所以基本上他的家人刚刚告诉他监狱比家好。是啊。监狱比他们一起创造的这个世界更好。所以迈克尔真的很受伤。迈克尔直到现在对马丁都没有意见。这是因为，你知道，不知何故他的员工，就像他的家人一样，认为还有其他更酷的地方。他说，不，这是最好的地方。伙计们，我们在这里过得很棒。他无法相信他们看不到他所看到的邓德·米夫林。嗯，我问韦恩拍摄那个休息室场景是什么感觉，因为他在这里，他是一个客串明星，他必须真正推动那个场景，你知道？我是说，我记得作为客串演员在节目里是什么感觉，那种事情有多吓人。所以我只是想听听从他的角度看，拍这个场景是什么感觉。这就是他要说的。来你们很棒的节目工作。它不是，尽管节目非常巨大，它并不吓人，只是因为每个人
in the finale or somewhere in the last season. So no, but I am curious. It does sound like Kevin is participating in some sort of... Something shady. Yeah, right. Because that's what it is. It's insider trading. It's not money laundering.
都像圣诞节早晨一样开心。就像他们不敢相信自己的好运。他们不敢相信他们能和谁一起工作，无论是在台前还是幕后，他们不敢相信剧本有多好笑。所以那个场景是，我喜欢那个场景。我喜欢那种像离开水的鱼，进入水里，
Martin didn't go to prison for money laundering. He went to prison for insider trading. I know, but this is the theory online that Dunder Mifflin is a front for money laundering. He went to prison for insider trading. I know, but this is the theory online that Dunder Mifflin is a front for money laundering. And I'm going to say I could see it. Oh, no, I could see it. I could see it. Because if you were going to have a money laundering front, by the way, I've also been watching a lot of Ozark. And that's all he does. If you watch Ozark, it's he's has to launder money for the drug cartel. So I'm like, oh my gosh, yes, a paper company. And you have to, you have like all this inventory, and then you have sort of like a boss who's kind of incompetent, who might not catch everything.
这样每个人都可以离开游泳池。如果这有什么意义的话，我真的不知道我在说什么。但是的，这是一个发挥你最好水平的轻松环境。所以是的，那天我知道，哦，得重做我的，因为那是最好的。凯特·鲍文我觉得那是最好的回应。凯特·鲍文好吧，珍娜，我有话要对你说。珍妮尔·沃尔顿什么？凯特·鲍文Pamela-ma-ding-dong。珍妮尔·沃尔顿哦，天哪。是啊。
Right? I think I, I can see it, Thomas. I can see it. But I'm also watching Ozark, so maybe that's informing me. All right. Well, in this scene, Martin fields a lot of questions from all of us about what prison was like. And he gives a rather sort of rosy view of prison. He's like, oh, yeah, we had outside time. We got to watch TV. I got to take some classes. Pam's like, they had watercolor classes in prison?
凯特·鲍文所以是10分38秒，安迪在用所有错误的方式搭讪帕姆。珍妮尔·沃尔顿不，吉姆脸上的表情说明了一切。这是一个很棒的恶作剧。进行得很顺利。然后我们有帕姆的谈话头，她说，那真是哇。所以她喜欢这个恶作剧。
Yeah. And then we're like, wow, Michael, it sounds like prison is better than Dunder Mifflin. We're kind of teasing Michael, right? And then Michael is just very upset at this implication that Dunder Mifflin is worse than prison. What you have to remember is that everyone at Dunder Mifflin is Michael's family and Dunder Mifflin is like his home away from home. So basically his family has just told him that prison is better than home. Yeah. Prison is better than this world that they've made together. And so Michael is really hurt. Michael had no issue with Martin until right now. And it's because, you
她很投入。嗯，她对吉姆以这种方式捉弄她的能力印象深刻。我想她在想，哇，我明白你要去哪儿了。现在珍娜，有一个删除场景，帕姆报复了他。是的，那在剧本里。这是故事中被剪掉的一部分。
know, somehow his employees, which are like his family, think that there's some other cooler place to be. And he's like, no, this is the best place to be. You guys, we have it amazing here. And he can't believe that they can't see Dunder Mifflin the way he can. Well, I asked Wayne what it was like to shoot that break room scene because here he was, he was a guest star and he had to really drive that scene, you know? And I mean, I remember what it was like
发生了一场恶作剧战争，对吧？是啊，是啊。所以帕姆给了安迪所有这些信息，关于所有那些对吉姆来说会是一个糟糕夜晚的事情，比如喝白俄罗斯酒。就像出去。是啊。去这家德国餐厅。她基本上是说，你知道吗，安迪？我没空，但吉姆会喜欢出去玩的。他会喜欢一个伙伴。
to be a guest actor on shows and how intimidating something like that could be. And so I just wanted to hear what was it like to do this scene from his perspective. Here's what he had to say. Coming to work on your guys awesome show. It wasn't, even though the show was so huge, it wasn't intimidating just because everybody
是啊，所以安迪说，你今晚干什么？我们要出去。吉姆说，哇，哇，哇，等等，等等。所以她确实报复了他。她确实报复了。但这并没有出现在这一集里，我觉得有点遗憾。因为后来，当吉姆要建议安迪去拿他的班卓琴并用高假声唱歌时，那实际上是对帕姆捉弄吉姆的回应。是啊，那就像吉姆比她更胜一筹。是啊。但相反，它看起来像是一个单方面的恶作剧。但在剧本里，实际上是他们俩互相捉弄。
was having like Christmas morning fun. Like they couldn't believe they're good fortune. They couldn't believe the people they get to work with, both in front and behind the camera, and they couldn't believe how funny the writing was. So that scene was, I love that scene. I love sort of being the fish out of water, getting into the water,
双方面的。是啊。嗯，在这个谈话头期间，我们有一个粉丝提问，安吉拉。很多人写信来。艾米丽·索托、托里·奎尔、安吉拉·C、哈什塔·V和莫妮卡·杰克斯都说，帕姆戴的项链是马还是独角兽？我们知道它的意义吗？帕姆的项链代表她生命中的不同时期吗？嗯，伙计们，它是独角兽。
so everybody can get out of the pool. If that makes any sense, I don't really know what I'm talking about. But yeah, it was an easy environment to do your best work. So yeah, I knew that day like, oh, got to redo my, because that's the shizzle. KATE BOWEN I thought that was the sweetest response. KATE BOWEN All right, Jenna, I have something to say to you. JANELLE WALTON What? KATE BOWEN Pamela-ma-ding-dong. JANELLE WALTON Oh, boy. Yeah.
帕姆以前戴过一条小爱心项链，但那是罗伊送的礼物。所以当他们分手时，她把它摘下来了。在服装部门，我们为帕姆选了一条新项链。这就是我们选的。现在，我很好奇。我深度挖掘了独角兽。你当然会。
KATE BOWEN So it's 10 minutes, 38 seconds, and Andy is hitting on Pam in all the wrong ways. JANELLE WALTON No, and the look on Jim's face, it says it all. This is a great prank. It's going great. And then we have the talking head from Pam, where she's like, that was wow. So she loves this prank.
KATE BOWEN：现在是10分38秒，安迪正在用各种错误的方式撩帕姆。JANELLE WALTON：没错，吉姆脸上的表情说明了一切。这是一个很棒的恶作剧。进展非常顺利。然后是帕姆的采访镜头，她说，哇，太棒了。所以她很喜欢这个恶作剧。
She's into it. Well, she's impressed at Jim's ability to prank her in this way. I think she's like, wow, I see where you're going. Now Jenna, there is a deleted scene where Pam gets him back. Yes, that is in the script. This is a portion of this story that got cut out.
她很享受。嗯，她对吉姆能用这种方式捉弄她感到印象深刻。我想她当时的心情是，哇，我明白你的意思了。珍娜，有一个删减片段是帕姆反过来捉弄他。是的，剧本里确实有这一段。这是故事中被剪掉的一部分。
There's a bit of a prank war that happens, right? Yeah, yeah. So Pam gives Andy all this information about all these things that would just be a horrible night out for Jim like drinking white Russians Like just going out. Yeah going to this German restaurant She basically is like, you know what Andy? I'm not available, but Jim would love to hang out. He would love a buddy
发生了一场恶作剧大战，对吧？是的，没错。帕姆给了安迪很多建议，告诉他哪些事情对吉姆来说会是一个糟糕的夜晚，比如喝白俄罗斯鸡尾酒，或者去那家德国餐厅。她基本上是说，你知道吗安迪？我没空，但吉姆很乐意出去玩。他很想找个伙伴。
Yeah, and so Andy's like, what are you doing tonight? We're going out. And Jim's like, Whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, wait. So she does get him back. She does. But that did not end up in the episode, which I think is a little bit unfortunate. Because later, when Jim is going to suggest to Andy that he go get his banjo and sing in a high falsetto, that was actually in response to Pam's prank on Jim. Yeah, that was was like Jim one-upping her. Yeah. But instead, it sort of seems like this one-sided prank. But in the script, it was actually both of them doing it to each other.
是的，然后安迪就问，你今晚干什么？我们要出去玩。吉姆说，等等，等等，等等。所以她确实反击了。是的。但这并没有出现在正片里，我觉得有点可惜。因为后来，当吉姆建议安迪去拿班卓琴并用高假声唱歌时，那其实是对帕姆捉弄吉姆的回应。是的，那就像是吉姆反将一军。没错。但现在看起来这像是一个单方面的恶作剧。但在剧本里，其实是他们俩互相捉弄对方。
A two-sided. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question during this talking head, Angela. A lot of people wrote in. Emily Soto, Tori Quill, Angela C, Harshita V, and Monica Jax all said, is the necklace that Pam wears a horse or a unicorn? Do we know its significance? And do Pam's necklaces represent different periods in her life? Well, guys, it is a unicorn.
双向的。是的。安吉拉，在这个采访镜头中我们收到一个粉丝提问。很多人写信来问。Emily Soto、Tori Quill、Angela C、Harshita V和Monica Jax都问，帕姆戴的项链是马还是独角兽？我们知道它的意义吗？帕姆的项链是否代表了她人生的不同阶段？伙计们，那是独角兽。
And Pam used to wear a little heart necklace, but it was a gift from Roy. And so when they broke up, she took it off. And with the wardrobe department, we picked a new necklace for Pam. And this is what we picked. Now, I am curious. I did a deep dive on unicorns. Of course you did.
帕姆以前戴过一条小爱心项链，那是罗伊送的礼物。所以当他们分手后，她就摘掉了。服装部门为帕姆挑选了一条新项链。这就是我们选的。现在，我很好奇。我深入研究了一下独角兽。你当然会这么做。
I'm sure my search history on my computer is like, IRS, United States Department of Labor, unicorn, unicorn, unicorn. Okay. Why did you guys pick it? And then I'm going to tell you what I found on the internet. We just liked how it looked. Okay. You just liked. We did not assign a particular significance to the fact that it was a unicorn. Okay. Well, lady, unicorns have been depicted in ancient seals that go back as far as the Bronze Age, the ancient Greeks. Unicorns are mentioned in the Old Testament of the Bible. What?
我敢肯定我的电脑搜索记录是这样的：国税局、美国劳工部、独角兽、独角兽、独角兽。好吧。你们为什么选它？然后我会告诉你们我在网上发现了什么。我们只是喜欢它的样子。好吧。你们只是喜欢。我们并没有赋予独角兽任何特殊的意义。好吧。天哪，女士，独角兽在青铜时代和古希腊的古代印章中就有描绘。圣经的旧约中也提到了独角兽。什么？
What's a symbol of strength? Yes. Unicorns go back to the Bible? Yes. The unicorn is mentioned in the Bible several times. The first verse I found was in Numbers 23, 22. God brought them out of Egypt. He hath as it were the strength of a unicorn. I mean, okay, so the unicorn symbol has been around for a long time.
什么是力量的象征？是的。独角兽可以追溯到圣经时代？是的。圣经中多次提到独角兽。我找到的第一节经文是在民数记23章22节。神领他们出埃及，他似乎有独角兽的力量。我的意思是，好吧，所以独角兽的象征已经存在很长时间了。
It's been associated with strength, fantasy, rarity, purity. It is Scotland's national animal. What? Yeah, when I was in Scotland, like you would see it in places, like you go into Edinburgh Castle and it's in the crest, you know? There's also another meaning for unicorn. You might want to take a minute and put some earmuffs on your kid's ears.
它一直与力量、幻想、稀有、纯洁联系在一起。它是苏格兰的国兽。什么？是的，当我在苏格兰的时候，你会看到它出现在一些地方，比如你去爱丁堡城堡，它就在纹章里，你知道吗？独角兽还有另一个含义。你可能想花点时间给你的孩子戴上耳罩。
The unicorn is also known as the third woman of a threesome. Oh. It's called a unicorn, which I probably jumped too far on this, but you have Jim, you have Karen, and you have Pam. Whoa! Wow. Is Pam the unicorn?
独角兽也被称为三人行中的第三个女人。哦。它被称为独角兽，我可能跳得太快了，但你有吉姆，你有凯伦，还有帕姆。哇！哇。帕姆是那只独角兽吗？
I don't know. I don't know. Okay, I need to reach out to Carrie Bennett in wardrobe and ask her if this unicorn pendant was as arbitrary as I thought it was. Because I like both of your explanations of unicorn. When you were describing the significance of unicorn, I'm like, yeah, strength, change, perseverance,
我不知道。我不知道。好吧，我需要联系服装部的凯莉·贝内特，问问她这个独角兽吊坠是否像我想的那样随意。因为你们对独角兽的解释我都喜欢。当你们描述独角兽的意义时，我在想，是的，力量、改变、毅力，
I'm into it, right. And, but then your third woman thing, I don't know. I'm just saying. I'm just saying. It could be. Well, listen, lady, on that note, I think we should take a break and then we will come back and see some of the changes that Michael has instituted at Dunder Mifflin to make life more like prison. Oh, fantastic. Your local Benjamin Moore retailer is more than a paint expert. There's someone with paint in their soul. A sixth sense honed over decades. And if you have a question about paint, it's almost as if they can read your mind.
我很感兴趣，对吧。但是关于那个“第三个女人”的说法，我不知道。我只是说说而已。我只是说说而已。有可能是。好吧，听着，女士，说到这里，我想我们应该休息一下，然后回来看看迈克尔在邓德·米夫林实施的一些让生活更像监狱的改变。哦，太棒了。你当地的本杰明·摩尔零售商不仅仅是油漆专家。他们是灵魂中带有油漆的人。一种经过几十年磨练的第六感。如果你有关于油漆的问题，就好像他们能读懂你的心思一样。
I sense. You need a two-inch angle brush for the trim in your family room. Regal selected an eggshell finish and directions to the post office. Benjamin Moore paint is only sold at locally owned stores. Benjamin Moore, see the love. Imagine a delicious ring of dough with a sweet mouthwatering spread on top. Sounds like a donut, right?
我感觉到。你需要一把两英寸的斜角刷来刷家庭活动室的装饰线条。Regal精选蛋壳光泽漆，还有去邮局的方向。本杰明·摩尔油漆只在当地拥有的商店出售。本杰明·摩尔，看见爱。想象一个美味的面团圈，上面涂着令人垂涎的甜酱。听起来像甜甜圈，对吧？
Well, if you spread new Philadelphia blueberry or new Philadelphia pineapple on top of your bagel, your bagel almost becomes a doughnut. It becomes a bonnet. Turn your bagel into a bonnet with new Philadelphia blueberry and Philadelphia pineapple made with real fruit. Breaking news, McDonald's international menu items are vanishing. McPizza bites missing in Italy. Big Rosti stolen from Germany.
好吧，如果你在百吉饼上涂上新的费城蓝莓或新的费城菠萝奶油奶酪，你的百吉饼几乎就变成了甜甜圈。它变成了一个“bonnet”。用含有真正水果的新款费城蓝莓和费城菠萝奶油奶酪把你的百吉饼变成“bonnet”。突发新闻，麦当劳的国际菜单项目正在消失。意大利的McPizza bites不见了。德国的Big Rosti被偷了。
Teriyaki chicken sandwich disappears in Japan. An Abysscoth McFlurry blackout in Belgium. Oh, it's just in. We can now confirm the stolen favorites have resurfaced at McDonald's Canada. The international menu heist. Try them all while you can. For a limited time and participating McDonald's in Canada.
日本的照烧鸡肉三明治消失了。比利时的Abysscoth McFlurry停售了。哦，刚刚收到消息。我们现在可以确认，这些被偷走的最爱已经在麦当劳加拿大重新出现了。国际菜单大劫案。趁现在尝试一下吧。限时供应，参与活动的加拿大麦当劳餐厅。
All right, so we are back. Michael announces to the group that he is quote, instituting some changes to make this more like prison, starting with one hour of outdoor time. So he makes everyone go down to the parking lot. They're all freezing. One of my favorite things about the scene is that he has two and a half pound weights in his trunk. Yeah. Well, he's not trying to bulk up. No, no, he just wants to tone. We had a fan question from Callie, Corinne, and Bernadette. When you guys were bundled up and went outside for rec time in the parking lot, was it actually cold out?
好了，我们回来了。迈克尔向大家宣布，他正在引用“实施一些改变，让这里更像监狱”，首先是每天一小时的户外活动时间。所以他让每个人都下到停车场。他们都冻坏了。关于这一幕，我最喜欢的事情之一是他的后备箱里有两磅半的哑铃。是的。好吧，他不是想练大块头。不，不，他只是想塑形。我们收到了来自卡莉、科琳和伯纳黛特的粉丝提问。当你们穿得严严实实去停车场进行娱乐活动时，外面真的很冷吗？
No. It was not cold at all. I looked it up. We shot this the week of October 2nd, but October is hot in Los Angeles, you guys. It stays really warm. Every October, I get suckered in to try to recreate like a fall woodland scene to my front yard. Like I buy all these pumpkins, I have like an autumn wreath.
不。一点也不冷。我查过了。我们是在10月2日的那个星期拍摄的，但洛杉矶的10月很热，你们知道的。天气一直很暖和。每年10月，我都会上当，试图在我的前院重现秋天的林地场景。比如我买了很多南瓜，我有一个秋天的花环。
I do this whole thing and every year my pumpkins like explode from the heat and turn to mush. And I have to like shovel them off the porch cause they're so flattened. Yeah, it was not cold, but I felt like we did a wonderful job of making ourselves look cold. We did great.
我做了这一切，每年我的南瓜都会因为高温而爆炸，变成糊状。我不得不把它们从门廊上铲走，因为它们太扁了。是的，一点也不冷，但我觉得我们把那种寒冷的感觉演得很好。我们做得很好。
I was like, hey, and they put all the ice on the ground and on the cars. Look at us acting and we look cold. We sold it. We did. All right, so then we go inside to the break room, where Michael is setting up a very sort of grainy television set for Kevin to watch.
我就像，嘿，他们把所有的冰都放在地上和车上。看看我们演的，我们看起来很冷。我们演得真像。我们做到了。好了，然后我们走进休息室，迈克尔正在为凯文设置一台非常粗糙的电视机。
And Martin shares with him that the TV in prison was a lot bigger. Yeah. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question from Graciela, Sydney, Joe, Brooke, and Leah. Was the weather forecast that Michael plays on the TV an actual weather forecast from a Scranton newsroom,
马丁告诉他，监狱里的电视大得多。是的。是的。好吧，我们收到了来自格拉谢拉、悉尼、乔、布鲁克和利亚的粉丝提问。迈克尔在电视上播放的天气预报是斯克兰顿新闻编辑室的真实天气预报，
or was it an actor? I don't know. Well, lady, I looked this up on the internet. And Dunderpedia, if you are correct, you say that it is the actual Scranton weather, that it is the actual Scranton weather, that it is the NBC weather station, it's WBRE NBC, and that that weather guy is Josh Hodel. Oh!
还是演员演的？我不知道。好吧，女士，我在网上查过了。Dunderpedia上说，如果你是对的，你说那是斯克兰顿的真实天气，那是NBC的天气台，是WBRE NBC，那个天气预报员是乔什·霍德尔。哦！
So, is that true, Josh Hodel? Is that you? You know what, that tracks for me. I feel like we would have that detail. I feel like we would. I feel like Filchay would have been all feel like we would. I feel like Phil Shea would have been all over that. Just like all of our menus, we're at local Scranton restaurants, things like that. I feel like Phil Shea would have been on that. I agree. So now should we talk a
所以，那是真的吗，乔什·霍德尔？是你吗？你知道吗，这对我来说很合理。我觉得我们会有那样的细节。我觉得我们会有的。我觉得菲尔·谢会关注这些的。就像我们所有的菜单，都是当地斯克兰顿餐馆的，诸如此类。我觉得菲尔·谢会处理好的。我同意。那么现在我们应该谈谈
little bit about how this prank is going? We mentioned it before. Andy is at Jim's desk and Jim's suggesting that he play, you know, the banjo for her and asks if he can sing in a high falsetto. And he's like, you know, I can. I loved it. It's so funny. Ed is having so much fun in that moment that I loved watching Ed get to do that. Well what we didn't talk about is that Karen comes up. Yeah. And she's
这个恶作剧进行得怎么样了？我们之前提到了。安迪在吉姆的办公桌前，吉姆建议他为她弹奏班卓琴，并问他是否可以用高假声唱歌。他说，你知道，我可以。我喜欢它。太搞笑了。埃德在那一刻玩得很开心，我喜欢看埃德做这些。好吧，我们没谈到的是凯伦过来了。是的。而且她
like, what are you guys doing? What I want in. I want to play. I'll be part of the prank. And wishy washy Jim shows up. He's like, uh, yeah, because he's caught now. He's caught now. And now if he had to explain this and who she was to him and all their pranking that they did together, now there's accountability and now he's backpedaling. Yeah, exactly. All right, Angela, should we go into the break room so that we can meet one of the most famous characters from The Office? This character is so famous.
说，你们在做什么？我想加入。我想玩。我要参与这个恶作剧。然后优柔寡断的吉姆出现了。他说，呃，是的，因为他现在被抓住了。他现在被抓住了。如果他必须解释这是什么，她对他来说是谁，以及他们一起做的所有恶作剧，现在有了责任，他现在在退缩。是的，完全正确。好了，安吉拉，我们去休息室吧，这样我们就能见到《办公室》里最著名的角色之一了。这个角色太出名了。
I mean, Jenna, I love roller skating. Stay with me here. All right. And I have found a community of people who love to roller skate online, on Instagram. And I was just sent, this gal won a roller skating competition dressed as Prison Mike. It's like amazing. Oh my gosh. I know. It's amazing. I might have to post it. It's so good. I put it in my Insta story, but she is phenomenal. But this character, people love Prison Mike. They love Prison Mike.
我是说，珍娜，我喜欢轮滑。听我说。好吧。我在网上，在Instagram上找到了一个喜欢轮滑的群体。我刚收到消息，这个女孩穿着“监狱迈克”的衣服赢得了轮滑比赛。这太神奇了。天哪。我知道。太神奇了。我可能得发出来。太棒了。我把它放在了我的Insta故事里，但她太出色了。但这个角色，人们喜欢监狱迈克。他们喜欢监狱迈克。
Jenna, I found the origin story for Prison Mike. What? It's in the deleted scenes. I have to read this to you guys and made everything make so much sense for me. All right. Okay. Hang with me as I get my notes.
珍娜，我找到了监狱迈克的起源故事。什么？在删除的场景里。我必须给你们读读这个，这让一切对我来说都变得很有意义。好吧。好的。等我拿一下我的笔记。
Michael Scott has a talking head that's in the deleted scenes. Listen to this. All right. He says, When I was just a little kid, we had an assembly at school where a giant owl came out and gave a very impassioned speech about giving hoots and not polluting. And you know what? I never polluted again. It was right then when I realized the power of saying things as a character.
迈克尔·斯科特有一个删除场景里的谈话头。听着。好吧。他说，当我还是个小孩子的时候，我们在学校有个集会，一只巨大的猫头鹰出来发表了一场非常激情的演讲，关于要大声疾呼，不要污染环境。你知道吗？我再也没有污染过环境。就在那时，我意识到以角色身份说话的力量。
People listen to you when you are wearing an elaborate costume or speaking in a voice that is not yours. I can't even speak. I, wow. Michael thinks, since he was a little boy, that the way you get people to listen to you and make changes is if you are a character. That's how they listen to you. I am so sad that this was deleted because not only does it speak to prison Mike, it speaks to every character Michael has ever done or ever
当你穿着精致的服装或用不是你自己的声音说话时，人们会听你的。我甚至说不出话来。我，哇。迈克尔认为，从他还是个小男孩起，让人听你说话并做出改变的方法就是成为一个角色。这就是他们听你的方式。我很难过这一段被删除了，因为它不仅说明了监狱迈克，它说明了迈克尔曾经做过或将要做的每一个角色。
will do. Because a giant owl told him something, and he paid attention. OK. Wow. He goes on, Jenna, there's another talking head, where he says, this isn't the first time he's done Prison Mike.
因为一只巨大的猫头鹰告诉了他一些事情，他注意到了。好的。哇。他继续说，珍娜，还有另一个谈话头，他说，这不是他第一次做监狱迈克了。
What? Yeah. He's done prison Mike. He's done- What? Yeah, he's done prison Mike before because he developed prison Mike in improv class. And he said he was in improv class and he was doing the scene and these two college kids, they just wouldn't stop talking. So I became prison Mike and I turned to them and I said,
什么？是的。他做过监狱迈克。他做过——什么？是的，他以前做过监狱迈克，因为他在即兴表演课上开发了监狱迈克。他说他在即兴表演课上，他正在做那个场景，那两个大学生，他们就是不停地说话。所以我变成了监狱迈克，我转向他们说，
hey, shut up or I'll stab you two's. Okay. Yeah. Wow. So not only had he done this character before, but he does characters when he wants people to pay attention. This is huge information. Angela, I know who came up with the idea of Prison Mike in the writer's room.
嘿，闭嘴，否则我就捅死你们两个。好的。是的。哇。所以他不仅以前做过这个角色，而且当他想让人注意时，他就会做角色。这是巨大的信息。安吉拉，我知道是谁在编剧室想出了监狱迈克的点子。
Who? All right. So, this script was written by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant, but we've established before that after a script is written by the original writer or writers, it always goes back to the writer's room for punch-up and rewrites and that scripts really are a kind of like collaborative effort, right? So when I was watching the scene, I thought to myself, this sounds like BJ Novak to me. Was it?
谁？好吧。所以，这个剧本是由瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特写的，但我们之前已经确定，在剧本由原作者或作者写完后，它总是会回到编剧室进行润色和重写，剧本确实是一种协作努力，对吧？所以当我在看这一幕时，我心想，这听起来像BJ·诺瓦克。是吗？
I texted BJ. I was like, BJ, I know that Stephen and Ricky wrote this episode. I know that Steven and Ricky wrote this episode. Did you come up with Prison Mike? Because I'm putting it on like you or maybe Mike, sure, but I think it's you. Here's what BJ told me. Well, in the lore of the writer's room, I get credit for Prison Mike, but it wasn't me. By the way, I love that the writer's room has a lore.
我给BJ发了短信。我说，BJ，我知道斯蒂芬和瑞奇写了这一集。我知道斯蒂芬和瑞奇写了这一集。是你想到监狱迈克的吗？因为我把它归功于你，或者可能是迈克，当然，但我认为是你的。这是BJ告诉我的。好吧，在编剧室的传说中，我因为监狱迈克而受到赞扬，但那不是我。顺便说一句，我喜欢编剧室有传说。
I want to know more about the writer's room lore. Well, I'm paraphrasing. He did not say lore, but he basically said, I have been given, I have the reputation of having written Prison Mike, but it actually wasn't me. So he said it was late one night and he was in Paul Lieberstein's office. It was him and Paul in Mindy. And they were tasked with having to punch up this scene in the conference room. The idea of the scene was that Michael
我想知道更多关于编剧室的传说。好吧，我在意译。他没有说传说，但他基本上说，我被赋予了，我有写监狱迈克的名声，但实际上不是我。所以他说那是深夜，他在保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室。是他、保罗和敏迪。他们的任务是润色会议室里的这一幕。这一幕的想法是迈克尔
was just going to convince us all that Dunder Mifflin was better than prison, but how? And he said that at the beginning of the meeting, Paul kind of offhandedly said, what if he plays a character? You know, like, I don't know, like prison Mike or something. But they quickly glossed over it. And they kept spitting out ideas and this and that and this and that.
只是要说服我们所有人邓德·米夫林比监狱好，但怎么说？他说在会议开始时，保罗随口说，如果他扮演一个角色会怎样？你知道，比如，我不知道，比如监狱迈克之类的。但他们很快就略过了。他们不断地吐出想法，这个那个，这个那个。
And then near the end of the meeting, BJ said something like, well, I really like this idea of him playing a character, Prison Mike, and that Mindy and Paul were like, Prison Mike, that's a brilliant idea. And BJ was kind of like, well, I was really just giving you your own idea back, but somehow he gets credited with Prison Mike. But he said, I think I would give it to Paul Lieberstein.
然后在会议快结束时，BJ说了一些类似的话，好吧，我真的很喜欢他扮演一个角色，监狱迈克的想法，敏迪和保罗说，监狱迈克，那是个绝妙的主意。BJ有点像，好吧，我真的只是把你的想法还给你，但不知何故他因为监狱迈克而受到赞扬。但他说是的，我想我会把它归功于保罗·利伯斯坦。
But it was the three of them together that then wrote those Prison Mike jokes. I love that. And I love that he had the crazy guys and dolls. Like, yes, that's in the script. Oh, my gosh. We actually had a ton of fan questions about this because it's such a good scene.
但正是他们三个人一起写了那些监狱迈克的笑话。我喜欢这个。而且我喜欢他有疯狂的“Guys and Dolls”。是的，那在剧本里。天哪。我们实际上收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问，因为它是一个非常好的场景。
So Kristen Went, Jordan C, Gina D, Megan M, Mark M, and many more wanted to know, were any of Steve's lines as Prison Mike improvised? Yes, some, because I looked at the script. But like the main ones, the ones that you remember, like about the gruel and the dementors, that was all in the script. That was all scripted.
所以克里斯汀·温特、乔丹·C、吉娜·D、梅根·M、马克·M等等很多人想知道，史蒂夫作为监狱迈克的台词有即兴发挥吗？是的，有一些，因为我看了剧本。但像主要的那些，你记得的那些，关于稀粥和摄魂怪的，那都在剧本里。那都是写好的。
There's little moments, like little things that Steve kind of added. But I would have to say the main points of Prison Mike are scripted. I feel like we can't do this episode without hearing a little bit of Prison Mike. Agree, Sam. I'm Prison Mike. You know why they call me Prison Mike?
有一些小瞬间，比如史蒂夫添加的一些小东西。但我不得不说监狱迈克的主要观点是写好的。我觉得如果不听一点监狱迈克，我们就不能做这一集。同意，萨姆。我是监狱迈克。你真的指望我们相信你是别人吗？你真的指望我不把你推到墙上吗，B.O.T.S.？哦，哇，伙计。好吧，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，这就是我们在监狱里的说话方式。太神奇了。Tanks。Tanks，tanks。伙计们，我在我的日记里写了这个场景，我必须告诉你们我写了什么。
Do you really expect us to believe you're somebody else? Do you really expect me to not push you up against the wall, B.O.T.S.? Oh, wow, man. All right, hey, hey, hey, hey, that's just the way we talk in the clink. Amazing. Tanks. Tanks, tanks. Guys, I wrote about this scene in my journal, and I have to tell you guys what I wrote.
天哪。这有点大，珍娜，因为我说，在会议室场景中，当史蒂夫变成监狱迈克时，他第一次转过身来，戴着那条头巾，用他疯狂的“Guys and Dolls”口音，我们都崩溃了，甚至史蒂夫也是，这从来没有发生过。因为它太荒谬了。
Oh my gosh. This is kind of a big thing, Jenna, because I said, in the conference room scene, when Steve became Prison Mike, the first time he turned around with that bandana on and his crazy guys and dolls accent, we all lost it, even Steve, which never happens. Because it was so ridiculous.
我们都笑喷了。然后我说，但如果你仔细看，你可以看到约翰和菲利斯几乎无法控制自己。如果你去16分3秒，你可以看到约翰破功了。我觉得我们所有人在这一整幕中都快要破功了。我们给杰夫·布里茨发了电子邮件关于这个
We all cracked up. And then I said, but if you watch really closely, you can see John and Phyllis are barely holding it together. And if you go to 16 minutes, three seconds, you can see John breaking. I feel like all of us are near breaking through this whole scene. We emailed Jeff Blitz about this
我们正在交换关于这一幕的信息。我对他说，我对这一幕的记忆是我们在这个会议室里做监狱迈克做了大约三天。我肯定没那么久，但我们花了很多时间在上面。他发来了这个关于它的音频片段。我想对于这样的场景，我的目标是，正如你们所知，我并没有试图以最快的速度完成它。
and we were trading messages about this scene. And I said to him, my memory of this was that we were in this conference room doing prison mic for like three days. I'm sure it wasn't that long, but we spent a long time on it. He sent in this audio clip about it. I think for scenes like this, that the goal of it, for me anyway, as you guys well know, I wasn't trying to do it with the most speed.
我能想象你们现在在笑。是的，我做到了，我知道对于这样的场景，有一种方法可以度过它，整个场景变得非常精简，但像这样的东西，感觉它需要，它只是感觉它需要……它直觉上感觉如果我能给史蒂夫更多的时间，整个场景的想法
I'm picturing you guys are laughing right now. Yeah, I do, I know that for scenes like this, there's a way to get through it where the whole of the scene gets really boiled down, but something like this, it felt like it needed to, it just it felt like it needed to... It just intuitively felt like that if I could give Steve more of a run at it, that the whole thought of the scene
就会传达出来。所以，是的，我知道。我知道对于演员来说这是一场苦差事。我知道我做它的方式是一场苦差事。然而，伙计，我喜欢这一幕。我喜欢。我只是喜欢它。好吧，我们都破功了，韦恩给珍娜发了电子邮件说他也在这一幕中破功了。我们问他他最喜欢的一些时刻是什么。这是他要说的。拍摄那一集《罪犯》有很多非常棒的时刻，
was just gonna come through. So, yes, I know. I know for the cast that it was a slog. I know the way I that it was a slog. I know the way I did it was a slog. And yet, man, I love this scene. I do. I just do. I love it. Well, we were all breaking Wayne emailed us Jenna that he broken the scene as well. And we asked him what some of his favorite moments were. And here's what he had to say. There were a lot of really great favorite moments shooting that episode, the convict,
还有拍摄之前的那一集《合并》。和斯坦利的时刻很棒。但我记得最清楚的是，显然整个监狱迈克的事情很搞笑。一次又一次，你知道，在史蒂夫做监狱迈克的时候不破功是非常困难的，我们破功了很多次。在那个会议室里，很热。我记得不得不经常擦汗。
and shooting the one before that, the merger. The moment with Stanley was great. But the one I remember most is, obviously the whole prison mic thing was hilarious. And take after take, you know, it was so very hard to not break while Steve was doing Prison Mike and we broke a lot. And in that conference room, it was pretty hot. I remember had to get wiped down for sweat a lot.
但在他监狱迈克例程快结束时有一个时刻。我相信他们在这一集中使用了这个特定的镜头，他说，所以谢谢你让我成为你生活的一部分，因为你有一个美好的生活。你有一个美好的生活。那是他第一次做第二个“你有一个美好的生活”。
But there's one moment towards the end of his Prison Mike routine. And they use this particular take in the episode, I believe, where he goes, so thanks for letting me be a part of your life because you got a good life. You got a good life. And that was the first time he had done the second, you got a good life.
摄像机在我后面，你可以看到我的脸颊鼓起来，因为我快要笑得爆炸了。我不想毁掉这个镜头，但那一整天在会议室里和监狱迈克在一起，相当特别。我必须说。是的，会议室相当特别，我必须说。是的，顺便说一句，我看了他谈论的那个时刻，你完全可以看到他在笑。
And the camera is behind me and you can see my cheeks bulge because I'm about to explode with laughter. I don't want to ruin the take, but that whole, that whole day in the conference room with Prism Mike was, was pretty special. I have to say. Yes. the conference room was pretty special, I have to say. Yes, and by the way, I looked at that moment he's talking about and you totally can see him smiling.
就像在他的后脑勺上，你知道他在笑。是的。就是其中之一。当我们拍摄时，这一幕对我们来说太搞笑了。我带着他的想法重看了那一幕，只是，你得排队。
It's like on the back of his head and you know he's smiling. Yeah. It's one of those. That's how funny the scene was to us when we were shooting it. I rewatched that with him in mind as well and just, you gotta get in line.
只是让我笑得太厉害了。它让我笑到了那个词。他记得会议室有多热，这确实让我笑得很厉害。因为珍娜，男人们讨厌会议室，因为他们会变得很热。这是我体温感觉还可以的地方。是的，一样。
Just made me laugh so hard. It like, made me laugh to the word. It did really make me laugh that he remembered how hot the conference room was. Because Jenna, the guys hated the conference room because they would get so hot. It was the one place where my body temperature actually felt okay. Yes, same.
这是我喜欢会议室场景的原因。我知道我不会冷。是的，我们知道我们不会冻死，但与此同时男人们像个汗流浃背的烂摊子，所以这让我笑了。我们在这个场景中也有一个粉丝发现，来自艾莉森·卡马达。她说，大约14分23秒，当每个人都在会议室时，我看到像某人的膝盖穿着短裤和靴子。
That was something about conference room scenes that I loved. I knew I wasn't going to be cold. Yes, we knew we wouldn't freeze to death, but meanwhile the guys were like a sweaty mess, so that made me laugh. We had a fan catch in this scene as well from Allison Kamada. She says, around 14 minutes and 23 seconds when everyone's in the conference room, I saw like someone's knee in a pair of shorts and boots.
这是摄像师吗？是的。谁，是兰德尔还是马特？我想是兰德尔。所以就在监狱迈克问你，安吉拉，如果你真的指望他不把你推到墙上之后，我们播放的那个片段，摄像机拉宽以显示整个小组有点像，
Was this the camera operator? Yes. Who, was it Randall or Matt? I think it was Randall. So it's right after Prison Mike asks you, Angela, if you really expect him not to push you up against the wall, that clip we played, the camera widens out to show the whole group sort of being like,
嘿，哇，哇，哇。如果你看最右边的角落，我想你可以看到兰德尔的膝盖。哦，我想去看看。因为我想他像栖息在角落里，他的摄像机对着史蒂夫。然后马特可能把他的摄像机对着你和小组。是的，因为马特会得到反应
hey, whoa, whoa, whoa. If you look in the far right corner, I think you can see Randall's knee. Oh, I want to go look. Because I think he's like perched in the corner there and he's got his camera on Steve. And then Matt probably had his camera on you and the group. Yes, cause Matt would get reactions
而兰德尔会有史蒂夫。是的，你是对的。我打赌那是兰德尔的膝盖。这是一个伟大的发现。是的。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。所以小组并没有给迈克尔他想要的。
and Randall would have Steve. And yes, you are right. I bet it's Randall's knee. That's a great catch. Yeah. I thought so too. I thought so too. So the group is not sort of giving Michael what he wants.
不。所以他诉诸于把他们锁在会议室里。他说，如果你想感受被监禁的感觉，给你。然后他走出了会议室。现在，这里有一点东西。那是一个非常假的锁。那扇门根本没锁。
No. So he resorts to locking them in the conference room. He's like, if you want to feel what it feels like to be imprisoned, here you go. And he walks out of the conference room. Now, here's a little something. That is such a fakey fake lock. That door did not lock at all.
我甚至不认为它关得很好。我还认为如果你看它，你可以看到史蒂夫在做一点戏法。我甚至不认为钥匙进了锁孔。我不认为那个锁孔一直都在那里。好吧，现在。我不能确定。因为我知道吉姆把德怀特锁在那里。是的，吉姆。这不是第一次有人一直都在那里。好吧，现在——我不能确定，因为我知道吉姆把德怀特锁在那里。
I don't even think it shut very well. I also think that if you look at it, you can see that like Steve is doing a bit of sleight of hand. I don't even think the key goes in the keyhole. I don't think that that keyhole has always been there. Well, now. I can't be sure. Because I know that Jim locks Dwight in there. Yes, Jim. It's not the first time someone's been always been there. Well, now- I can't be sure, because I know that Jim locks Dwight in there.
是的，吉姆，这不是第一次有人被锁在那里。德怀特被锁在那里。但在那一个，我再次想指出，看起来没有地方可以锁任何人。是的，没有锁孔。我看不到吉姆真的把他锁在那里的任何可能方式。看起来，这都是非常假的戏法。好了，我们在哪里？我们在哪里？我们被锁在会议室里。帕姆给托比打电话。
Yes, Jim, it's not the first time someone's been locked in there. Dwight was locked in there. But in that one, again, I meant to point out that it looks like there's nowhere to lock anyone in. Yeah, there's no keyhole. I see no possible way that Jim actually locked him in there. It looks, it's all very fakey-fake sleight of hand. All right, where are we? Where are we? We're locked in the conference room. Pam calls Toby.
帕姆给托比打电话，托比向迈克尔解释，迈克尔，他们只是在逗你。当然他们知道监狱比邓德·米夫林更糟。当他意识到自己被逗时，他脸上的表情，他立即原谅了每个人，他很高兴能成为笑话的一部分。完全正确。他就像，哦，他们确实明白了。他们确实喜欢这里。他们确实喜欢我。
Pam called Toby and Toby explains to Michael, Michael, they're just teasing you. Of course they know that prison is worse than Dunder Mifflin. The look on his face when he realizes he's being teased, he like, he immediately forgives everyone and he's just so delighted to be part of a joke. Exactly. He's like, oh, they do get it. They do like it here. They do like me.
他们在这里很开心。这是一个笑话。哦，我现在明白了。所以现在迈克尔有一个谈话头，他解释说马丁辞职了。珍娜，你怪他吗？我的意思是，不，我不怪他。我的意思是你怎么能在那里工作？
They are happy here. It's a joke. Oh, I get it now. So now Michael has a talking head, and he explains that Martin has quit. And Jenna, do you blame him? I mean, no, I don't blame him. Like how do you work there now?
而且你必须记住这完成了该节目的故事弧，每周都会有一个斯坦福员工离开。是的。好吧，我注意到了什么。当马丁离开时，他正在进入电梯，你看到他，他拿着他的盒子，梅雷迪思正从电梯走回办公室。这让我意识到，等一下，她不在会议室的监狱迈克场景里。
And also you have to remember this fulfills a story arc for the show that each week a Stanford employee is going to go. Yeah. Well, I noticed something. When Martin is leaving, he's getting into the elevator and you see him, he's carrying his box of things, Meredith is walking out of the elevator back into the office. And that made me realize, wait a second, she was not in the prison mic scenes in the conference room.
不。然后我们收到了来自乔伊·莫林的粉丝提问，说，等一下，梅雷迪思一直都在哪里？有没有删除的场景解释为什么她上班这么晚？安吉拉，请帮帮我和乔伊。好吧，女士们，删除的场景里有一整条线索，解释了这一切。所以梅雷迪思说她的车在修理厂
No. And then we got a fan question from Joy Morin that says, wait, where was Meredith all this time? Is there a deleted scene that explains why she's so late to work? Angela, please help me and Joy out. All right, ladies, there is a whole runner in the deleted scenes and it explains all of this. So Meredith says that her car's in the shop
她需要搭车去取车，马丁主动提出载她一程。德怀特和安吉拉，因为他们对马丁以及他为什么去监狱如此怀疑，他们有整个像，我不知道，像他们是案件的侦探。他们也有整个线索。但梅雷迪思去修理厂取车了。所以这就是梅雷迪思所在的地方。是的。我为凯特感到难过，她不在车里。我知道。我也这么想，珍娜。我当时想，天哪，凯特没能坐在那里，不得不咬住嘴唇，这样她就不会在监狱迈克面前大笑。
and she needs a ride to go get it and Martin offers to give her a ride. Dwight and Angela, because they are so suspicious of Martin and why he went to prison, they have this whole like sort of like, I don't know, like they're detectives on the case. They have a whole runner as well. But Meredith goes to get her car out of the shop. So that's where Meredith is. Yeah. I feel bad for Kate that she wasn't in the car. I know. That's what I thought too, Jenna. I was like, oh my gosh, Kate didn't get to sit in there and have to bite the inside of her mouth so she didn't laugh out loud at Prison Mike.
我想的一样。因为你有一个美好的生活。你有一个美好的生活。好了，现在我们有最后一幕。安迪正在为帕姆弹奏班卓琴，并用高假声唱《Rainbow Connection》。很多人写信谈论这一幕。让我们听听。他们说了什么？好的。
I thought the same thing. Because you got a good life. You got a good life. All right, so now we have the final scene. Andy is playing the banjo for Pam and singing Rainbow Connection in a high falsetto. A lot of people wrote in about this scene. Let's hear it. What'd they say? Okay.
莱斯利·G、阿什利·G、艾娃·H、艾丽莎·C和凯莉·C都说，珍娜，当埃德为你唱歌时，你是怎么度过最后那一幕的？你有没有破功大笑？是的，像一百万次。但我必须说点什么。我喜欢班卓琴。我喜欢班卓琴。
Leslie G, Ashley G, Ava H, Alyssa C, and Carrie C all said, Jenna, how did you get through that scene at the end when Ed is singing to you? Did you ever break and laugh? Yes, like a million times. But I have to say something. I love the banjo. I love the banjo.
你和我，珍娜，谈过很多次。我们告诉埃德，我们和他在一起最美好的回忆之一是当他拿出班卓琴，克里德拿出他的曼陀林，他们演奏的时候。我不想这一幕结束。这非常有趣。作为珍娜，我必须喜欢恶作剧，讨厌班卓琴。但在现实生活中，我讨厌恶作剧，喜欢班卓琴。
And you and I, Jenna, have talked about this a lot. And we've told Ed that some of our fondest memories on set with him are when he would get out the banjo and Creed would get out his mandolin and they would play. I did not want this scene to end. This was very funny. As Jenna, I had to love a prank and hate the banjo. But in real life, I hate a prank and I love the banjo.
所以我喜欢做这一幕，我不想它结束，我们是在，我想我们是在周末结束时拍摄的。所以这又是那些没有多少人在周围的场景之一。只有我们几个人，当这种情况发生时，总是感觉你可以花所有的时间。没有人等着你。这是我和埃德做那一幕最美好的回忆之一。我喜欢它。
So I loved doing this scene and I didn't want it to end and we filmed it at the end of, I think we filmed it at the end of the week. And so it was again one of those scenes where there weren't many people around. It was just a few of us and it always felt like you could take all the time in the world when that was the case. No one was waiting on you. And it's one of my fondest memories is doing that scene with Ed. I loved it.
所以我们问杰夫·布里茨拍摄这一幕是什么感觉，这是他要说的。所以最后一幕，那首歌，我也喜欢。我太喜欢了。我喜欢安迪，我太喜欢了。我喜欢安迪，它太甜了，对帕姆来说太糟糕了，但它也太甜了。我不知道，伙计。你知道，我会说关于它，
So we asked Jeff Blitz what it was like to shoot the scene, and this is what he had to say. So that final scene, that song, I loved that too. I loved it so much. I love that for Andy I loved it so much. I love that for Andy it's so sweet and for Pam it's so bad, but it's so sweet also. I don't know, boy. You know, I will say about it though,
我想这是关于试图弄清楚它应该达到什么程度。歌越好笑，就意味着安迪对自己的感觉和世界被它改变了。所以我确实认为那里有很多关于它的讨论，你知道吗？所以安吉拉，我在剧本中注意到关于这一幕的一件事是吉姆不在那一幕中。剧本里只有安迪为帕姆弹奏班卓琴。现在这样太美了，对吧？
I think it was about trying to figure out to what extent should it be such. The funnier the song is, it just means that Andy's sense of himself and the world is changed by that. So I do think there was a lot of talk about it there, you know? So Angela, something that I noticed in the script about this scene is that Jim is not in that scene. It's just in the script, Andy playing the banjo for Pam. And it's so beautiful the way it is now, right?
你从帕姆看着吉姆，然后吉姆看着摄像机。这很完美。我问杰夫关于它，他说是的，那是他添加吉姆在最后的主意。他实际上说他忘了告诉每个人那是他的主意，在那一天他们已经开始送约翰回家，他们不得不让他回来。叫他回来。是的，他们不得不像，他说他的日程安排有点乱。这是他说的，他说我真的很喜欢在那里揭示吉姆享受
That you have this rack focus from Pam looking to Jim and then Jim looking to camera. It's perfect. And I asked Jeff about it and he said yeah that was his idea to add Jim at the end. He actually said that he forgot to tell everybody that that was his idea and on the day they had like started to send John home and they had to like get him back. Call him back. Yeah they had to be like he said it was a little bit of a mess with his schedule. Here's what he said he said I really do love revealing Jim there enjoying the
他让帕姆经历的疯狂，以一种奇怪的方式，即使它是高度讽刺的，被当作一个笑话，这是吉姆在那一刻能接近亲自为帕姆小夜曲的最接近的方式。啊。是的。好吧，是的，对我来说，那一刻没有吉姆就不起作用，因为最后那一刻是他和帕姆调情并建立联系。是的。
lunacy of what he's put Pam through and in a weird way even though it's heavily ironic and played off as a joke this is the closest Jim can come in that moment to serenading Pam himself. Aw. Yeah. Well, yeah, to me, that moment doesn't work without Jim there because that final moment is him and Pam getting to flirt and have a connection. Yeah.
他们现在必须通过一个渠道来做。就像，再一次，他们不能互相交流，因为有其他人在路上。所以他们必须找到绕过它的方法。是的，那全是杰夫·布里茨。我喜欢所有这些音频片段，珍娜，杰夫给我们的，还有韦恩，它们真的让我对这一集打开了很多。
They just now have to do it through a conduit. Like, once again, they can't communicate to one another because there's other people in the way. So they have to find ways around it. Yeah, that was all Jeff Blitz. I love all of these audio clips, Jenna, that Jeff gave us and Wayne, and they really just open up the episode for me so much.
我不知道你们是否听到了这个，这是杰夫会继续谈论的事情，但杰夫有口吃。我不知道你们是否听到了这个，这是杰夫会继续谈论的事情，但杰夫有口吃。他有点紧张制作音频片段。然后他实际上发来了这个我们想为你播放的音频片段，关于他觉得他的口吃对他来说是一个优势。这里，听听他要说什么。
And I don't know if you guys heard this, and it's something Jeff will go on to talk about, but Jeff has a stutter. And I don't know if you guys heard this, and it's something Jeff will go on to talk about, but Jeff has a stutter. And he was a little nervous about making the audio clips. Then he actually sent in this audio clip that we want to play for you about how he felt like his stutter was an advantage to him. Here, listen to what he has to say.
作为旁注，我想说这个，口吃的事情，我相信对于其中一些东西来说，它听起来很响亮和清晰，它是部分，当我开始和你们一起工作时，我非常害怕口吃会使它变成这样，当我想要和你们分享笔记时，我会，它需要的时间，然后我会尴尬
As a side note, I want to say this, that the stuttering thing, which I'm sure that is coming through loud and clear for some of this stuff, it is part, when I started working with you guys, I was so scared that the stuttering was gonna make it such that when I wanted to share notes with you, that I would, that the amount of time it would take to do it and then I'd be embarrassed
所有那些东西。但无论如何，我确实认为它激发了一些东西，比如，与其对演员大喊笔记，不如我去，对我来说，对我来说，它只是感觉不那样做是一件更好的事情。所以我认为它变成了一些东西，笔记有一种体贴，我可以和人们谈论它，它感觉我可以以一种方式旋转它，它使那个，对我来说，感觉是一件好事。
and all that stuff. But anyway, I do think it inspired something where like, rather than shout notes out to the cast that I would go and that for me, for me, it just it felt like a better thing to not do that. And so I think it turned into something where the note had a thoughtfulness to it and I could talk to people about it and it felt like I could spin it in a way that it made that, for me anyway, feel like a good thing.
它在播客上没那么好，对不起。但无论如何，是的，只是想说那个。好吧，这很有趣，安吉拉，因为我对和杰夫一起工作的记忆是亲密的、私人的对话，非常紧密。所以我从来没有发现他的口吃妨碍了与他的联系。事实上，我认为他是对的。
It's not as good on a podcast, I'm sorry. But anyway, yeah, just wanted to say that. Well, it's interesting, Angela, because my memories of working with Jeff are of close, intimate conversations that were very connected. And so I never found his stutter to get in the way of connecting with him. In fact, I think he's right.
我认为它实际上创造了更深层的联系，因为我们有这些一对一的对话。我对和杰夫在一起的记忆是这些安静、亲密的对话，加上笑得比我笑过的任何时候都厉害。是的，是的，我绝对同意这一点。这就是为什么我迫不及待地想和杰夫讲“拯救班迪特”的故事，因为那天我们排练时，我和杰夫、肯特和格雷格在片场，把猫弄进天花板。我不会深入讨论它，但我告诉你，我为那个播客活着，因为我想要他们所有人。我想要我们所有人重述这个故事。
I think it actually created a deeper connection because we had these one-on-one conversations. My memories of being around Jeff are of these quiet, intimate conversations coupled with laughing harder than I've ever laughed. Yes, yeah, I absolutely agree with that. And that's why I cannot wait to tell the story of Save Bandit with Jeff, because it was me and Jeff and Kent and Greg on set that day when we rehearsed it, getting the cat in the ceiling. I'm not going to get into it, but let me tell you, I am living for that podcast because I want all of them. I want us all to retell the story.
天哪。我们应该让你们所有人聚在一起，我们应该做一个特别的“拯救班迪特”，每个人都说出他们对那一幕的记忆。一个“拯救班迪特”深度挖掘。是的。是的。我喜欢那个。好吧，伙计们，我们也有来自韦恩·威尔德森的最后一个音频片段。他只是让我们知道他现在正在做的一些事情以及你可以在哪里找到他。好吧，我确实在亚马逊Prime上上传了格雷格·丹尼尔斯的节目。
Oh my gosh. We should get all you guys to come together and we should do a special save bandit where everyone speaks their memories of that scene. A save bandit deep dive. Yes. Yes. I love that. Well, guys, we also have a final audio clip from Wayne Wilderson. He's just letting us know a few of the things he's doing now and where you can find him. Well, I did upload on Amazon Prime with Greg Daniels.
我知道他们已经被续订了第二季，所以希望我们会看到我回到那个节目。你可以去寻找我和另一位办公室校友兰德尔·艾因霍恩一起做的工作的重播，我在《米克》中扮演校长，呃是的哦，你可以在哪里找到我？在Twitter上我是韦恩·威尔德森。一个词。在Facebook上。我是韦恩·威尔德森。一个词。在Instagram上。我是韦恩·威尔德森。那是一个词。
I know they've been picked up for a second season, so hopefully we'll be seeing me back on that. You can go find reruns of work I did with another Office alum Randall Einhorn where I played the principal on the MICK and uh yeah oh where can you find me? On Twitter I'm Wayne Wilderson. One word on Facebook. I'm Wayne Wilderson. One word and on Instagram. I'm Wayne Wilderson. That's one word.
你们想念你们。非常感谢你们让我来到你们很棒的播客。这很有趣。好了。回头见。他让我笑。他设置那个的方式，我以为他会为他的Instagram说些不同的东西，
You guys miss you. Thank you so much for letting me come on your awesome podcast. It's been a lot of fun. All right. Later. He makes me laugh. The way he was setting that up, I thought he was gonna say something different for his Instagram,
但我知道他的Instagram是韦恩·威尔德森一个词，所以……无论如何，顺便说一句，不是韦恩·威尔德森一个词。只是韦恩·威尔德森。是的。一个词。完全正确。只是韦恩·威尔德森。是的。一个词。完全正确。这是他的名字组合，伙计们。
but I know his Instagram is Wayne Wilderson One Word, and so... Anyway, by the way, it's not Wayne Wilderson One Word. It's just Wayne Wilderson. Yeah. One Word. Exactly. It's just Wayne Wilderson. Yeah. One word. Exactly. It is his name combined, guys.
你可以在Twitter上找到杰夫·布里茨，地址是Jeffree Blitz。杰夫，韦恩，非常感谢。伙计们，那是《罪犯》。那是《罪犯》。非常感谢你们的收听和发送你们的问题。我们下周见，带着《本尼·汉纳圣诞节》的第一部分。已经是圣诞节了，这将是两部分。
And you can find Jeff Blitz on Twitter at Jeffree Blitz. Jeff, Wayne, thank you so much. Guys, that was The Convict. That was The Convict. Thank you so much for listening and sending in your questions. We will see you next week with part one of Benny Hanna Christmas. It's Christmas already and it's gonna be a two-parter.
而且我们有客人。哦，我们很兴奋。下周见。再见。感谢收听“办公室女士的第二杯饮料”。这一集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。“办公室女士”是Odyssey的呈现，
And we have guests. Oh, we're excited. See you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey
由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jorkins，音频工程师兼助理制片人是Molly Nugent。Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。《Office Ladies》由Bill Schultz进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。